الله يغفر للوالد كان له مثل
يقول: «مليون في دربه، ولا ريال في غير دربه»
تعالوا نبي ننظم المطبخ، ونحوله من مركز تكلفة إلى ربح
وصارت تجينا الضغوط أن افتحوا لنا، وأرسلوا لنا
وبندفع فلوس تكفون ما يخالف
فاضطرينا فعلًا نفتح لبعض الأصدقاء والأقارب
اضطريت، أنتوا ما تبون
هذا سُقراط من إذاعة ثمانية، وأنا عمر الجريسي
أستضيف قادة التحول والأعمال والرأي
ضيف حلقة اليوم هو الأستاذ عبد العزيز بن محمد السبيعي
عضو مجلس إدارة شركة «ماسك»
الشّركة اللي تُعتبر نموذج حبينا أننا نركز عليه، ونتوسع فيه
لحوكمة، وتنظيم الشّركات العائليّة
80% من الشّركات السّعودية، عائلية
المعلومة الأهم 90% من الشّركات العائليّة تنهار بعد الجيل الثاني
وهذه خسارة اقتصادية هائلة جدًّا
فتجربة «ماسك» كانت جدًّا مشجّعة في كيف تنظيم
وترتيب العمل العائلي
يُحافظ على العلاقات الأسرية، يعظّم الثروة العائليّة
وذكرنا بالأرقام، ويساعد على عمل خيري مُستدام، ويرتب الشؤون العائليّة
كل هذه كانت محاور حلقتنا، واللي ختمنا فيها في النهاية بوصفة
يُوصي بها ضيفنا لكل من هو مهتم بهذا الشأن
احنا اليوم في مرحلة تحول اقتصادي، العديد من الشّركات تتأسّس
والعديد من الشّركات تتحول، فمهم أنها تُراعي مثل هذه الوصفة
لتبني شركة تستمر 100 عام وأكثر، بإذن الله، أترككم مع الحوار
حيّاك الله، أبو خالد شرفتنا ونورتنا
شكرًا أبو عبد الرحمن، شاكر لك على الاستضافة
وإن شاء الله، نتمنى نقدم شيء يكون مُفيد
أنا متأكد، آسفين على اللي سويناه في المكتب
تغيّر بشكل كبير، ما أدري أيش سويتوا
وين المكتب أصلًا؟
زين اللي أخوي «إبراهيم» رئيس مجلس الإدارة ما هو موجود
وللا كان حاسبك، قال: على حساب مين، ومين اللي جاء، وشال؟
لا أشوه أن ما هو موجود
كان حط التكاليف كلها علي، الله يسامحك
لا تعمله تكفى
لا والله احنا ممتنين، وشاكرين لك قبولك الدعوة
يلا جات الموافقة، وأنت مُقل في الظهور، أيش السبب؟
والله يا أبو عبد الرحمن جزء منها ثقافة العائلة
تعرف، الله يغفر له ويرحم الوالد
كان من القيم اللي يعتنقها في العمل هو عدم الظهور الإعلامي
ولأسباب كثيرة، وأنا وإخواني وخواتي، والعائلة بشكل عام
مقتنعين بهذه الأسباب فعلًا مفيدة
الظهور الإعلامي تعرف سلاح ذو حدين
وطبيعة عمل المشاريع التجارية فيه أخطاء، ومناطق رمادية كثير
فالظهور الإعلامي قد يُسبب لك مشاكل أنت في غنى عنها
أنا أشكرك أنك قبلت هذا الاستثناء، وظهرت معانا للمصلحة العامة
كان الدافع ما هو الحديث عن التجربة التجارية
ما هو محور تركيزنا الأساسي، لأن هذا مو بتركيز بودكاست سُقراط
لكن التركيز هو على تجربة الحوكمة، ومَؤْسَسة العمل
والانتقال من جيل إلى جيل
واللي هي دائمًا تكون معضلة في الشّركات العائليّة
احنا يمكن عندنا رقمين مرعبة إذا أخذناهم مع بعض
الرقم الأول أن حدود 80% من الشّركات في السّعودية، هي عائلية
وهذه نسبة قريبة من اللي في العالم
النسبة الثانية المرعبة مع هذه النسبة هي أن أكثر من 88 أو 90%
من الشّركات العائليّة في العالم تنهار في الجيل الثالث
وهذا هدر وخسارة اقتصادية غير عادية
فالأصل هو فناء الشّركات العائليّة
الاستثناء والقلّة هم اللي لَقوا الوصفة حقت الاستمرار
فأنتوا من القلة اللي عندكم تجربة رهيبة في هذا الجانب
وأنت تقود هذا المشروع من 2011 أو 2010، وراح نسولف فيها
فكان هذا هو محور الحلقة، فأنا أشكر لك قبولك الدعوة
ونشكر العائلة قبولها أن أنت تظهر، لأن هذا يخالف سياستكم
لكن في مصلحة عامة من مشاركة هذه التجربة
والله بكل أمانة لما استأذنت العائلة في الظهور
ما أُخفيك الأغلبية بسيطة وافقوا، بس في جزء كبير كان معارض
زي ما قلت لك: لأن هذا مخالف لسياستنا
لكن أنت هزيتني في كلمة قلتها
وهذا اللي خلّاني أرجع وأحارب وأقنعهم
وأقول لهم: إلا لازم نظهر، يوم قلت لي أنت: أمانة في رقبتكم
إي والله
أنكم تشاركون التجارب بسلبياتها وإيجابياتها مع العوائل
لأن فعلًا زي ما تفضلت
أن كثير من العوائل بحاجة إلى أنها تعرف أيش الأساليب بالشغل
أنا ما أقول: أن اللي سويناها في «ماسك» مناسب لكل العوائل
احنا اللي سويناه مناسب لنا، وفي أشياء قد لا تكون مناسبة لغيرنا
لكن بكل أمانة هذا السبب الأساسي لظهوري اليوم
وأشكر إخواني وخواتي اللي سمحوا لي بالظهور
وأتمنى أنك ما تسال أسئلة حسّاسة تزعلهم مني
لا، مانا مزعلينهم أبد
يتندمون أنهم طلعوني
لا، راح تكون أنا متأكد
بس أبي أشير لنقطة بأمانة، المشروع ما هو مشروعي
أنت قلت: أن أنت كنت تقود المشروع، أنا والله ما كنت أقوده
أنت بتستغرب يمكن من هذا الكلام، وبندخل في تفاصيل
المشروع يمكن قاده رؤية الوالد، الله يرحمه
بس الأهم هو اتحاد الأبناء والبنات
ورغبتهم القوية في أنهم يبقون مع بعض، وبالذات البنات
أنا أقول لك: خواتي البنات أنا فخور
أنتم ثلاثة أولاد، وسبعة بنات
ما شاء الله
وما أبالغ
إذا قلت لك: أن سبب اليوم وصولنا لهذه المرحلة بشكل كبير
يعود للبنات، ليش؟ وإذا تبغى ندخل في التفاصيل
إي أبد تفضل
لأن البنات آمنوا بهذا المشروع، وهم برة الشّركة
احنا العيال كنا داخلين وشايفين وعارفين، ومستمتعين بالعمل
البنات ما كان، تعرف في فترة من الفترات ما كان في أي شفافية
وهذا العرف في أغلب الشّركات العائلة
ولا كان في أي مشاركة لأي معلومات، ولا مشاركة لهم في اتخاذ القرار
الوالد كان يدير واحنا معه، وماشية الأمور
فآمنوا بدون ما يكونون داخلين الشّركة، والحمد لله
أقول لك: هذا سبب أساسي في اليوم للي وصلت له «ماسك» بكل أمانة
وهذه اللي راح تكون المحور الأساسي لحلقتنا
موضوع تجربتكم في الحوكمة، والخطوات اللي مريتوا فيها
بس قبلها خلينا نستعرض بشكل سريع تاريخ الأسرة التّجاري
بس عشان اللي ما هو عارف، أو كشركة ما تحب الظهور الإعلامي
يمكن مو بالكل يعرف أيش هي «ماسك»
خلينا نذكر بشكل سريع تجربة العم «محمد» الله يرحمه
شلون بدأت، أهم المحطات، وبعدين نوصل لموضوع الحوكمة
والفصل بين «العم محمد، وعبد الله» الله يرحمهم
الوالد بدأ في العمل التجاري، تعرف هو مولود في عنيزة
توفي والده وهو عمره إحدى عشر سنة
واضطر أنه يسافر لمكة طلبًا للرزق، وعمره إحدى عشر سنة
طلع من عنيزة راح لـمكة يشتغل مع عمّه «ناصر»
واشتغل في مهن دُنيا كثير قبلما يؤسس أول عمل تجاري
كان بالشراكة مع العم «سليمان الغنيم» الله يغفر له ويرحمه
ويغفر لهم جميع، إن شاء الله
هذا الكلام كان قبل نحو ثمانين أو خمسة وثمانين سنة من الآن
ومنها انطلق العمل التجاري
أيش كان المجال؟
كان زي أي تُجّار في ذاك الوقت، مُشكل كل شيء
يبيع كلش
أقمشة وبشوت، وكان أذكر، الله يغفر له ويرحم الوالد
كان يقول: أي شيء نجيبه من الحجّاج يشترونه، وللا أي مواد
ويرسلونها لـ«نجد» وللا «القصيم» تُباع
فكان يشتغل في كل شيء
الملابس والأدوات والسكر أحيانًا، المواد البترول والغاز أي شيء
العملات ما بعد بدأ فيها لسّه؟
في مواسم الحج يشتغل عملات بس
بعدها انضم له العم «عبدالله» احتاج إلى مساعدة، وانضم له
أخوه الأصغر؟
أخوه الأصغر نعم، جابهم من عنيزة واستقرّوا في مكة معه
وانضم له في العمل، والشراكة مع العم «سليمان الغنيم»
كانت على أساس أنها ثلاثة شهور هي، واستمرت ثلاثين سنة
فبعدما انتهت الشراكة بيننا وبين العم «سليمان الغنيم»
استمرت الشراكة بين الوالد والعم «عبد الله»
وصار التركيز هنا على موضوع الصّرافة والخدمات المصرفية
والقطاع المالي، والعقاري جت في مرحلة لاحقة
وهذه كانت، احنا نتكلم على طفرة السبعينيات والثمانينات
إي نعم
اللي كان فيها
صحيح
أنتوا كنتوا أو العم «محمد» كان أيش يُسمى؟ دكان صرافة، وللا بنك؟
ما كانت بنوك ذاك الوقت
لا، كان مصرف، كان شركة «محمد وعبدالله إبراهيم السبيعي للصرافة»
هذا اللي انعرفت، وانشهرت فيه الأسرة
زي ما تفضلت من السبعينيات وطالع
وهذا كان محور العمل العائلي، وخلني أقول لك الأساس أو القاعدة
اللي انطلقت منها لأعمال أخرى
وكنشاط تجاري في إيرادات، ومداخيل جيدة
هذه المداخيل تعيدون استثمارها في القطاع العقاري، فبنى
بالضبط
محفظة عقارية هي اللي ممكن نمّت الثروة بشكل أكبر
صحيح، صدقت
جات لحظة متقدمة في 2008-2009-2010
في هذيك المراحل قرّرتوا الفصل
عطنا كواليس، وشلون وصلتوا لتلك اللحظة، وسويتوها؟
في عام 2010 كان قرار الفصل
الوالد والعم اكتشفوا أن الأفضل يكون في استقلاليّة
في ملكيّة العمل التجاري بين الطرفين
ويمكن لو تسألني بكل أمانة أيش السبب الرئيسي لهذا القرار اللي يمكن
ما كان متوقع ما أخفيك، احنا كنا متعودين وعلاقة الوالد بالعم قوية جدًّا
وأنا وعيال عمي، وخواتي وبنات عمي ترانا أسرة واحدة
وتعرف في بينا، وذكريات جميلة والطفولة
لكن لو تسألني، أيش السبب اللي خلانا نوصل لهذه المرحلة؟
وهذا يمكن اللي خلانا نأخذ قرار مصيري في تنظيمنا
هو دخول الأبناء في العمل العائلي
الجيل الثاني، أبناء «محمد، وعبدالله»
بالضبط، ويمكن دخولنا كان بطريقة يمكن من
أنا بالنسبة لي أنها من أسوأ الطرق
في طرق يمكن أفضل بكثير لدخول الأبناء والبنات في العمل العائلي
لكن الطريق اللي كنا شغّالين فيها أول
أو كنا نشتغل فيها أول ما كانت أبدًا هي الطريقة الصحيحة
شلون؟
كانت مقسمة إلى إما مناطق أو قطاعات
وكل ولد مسؤول عن يا منطقة يا قطاع
فهذه شوية سببت، تعرف لما تكون أنت في منطقة
معناته أنت لك علاقة بالمسؤول عن القطاع
وفي نفس الوقت الصلاحيات، والمسؤوليات ما كانت واضحة
فكان في كثير من، خلني أقول لك: الشد في الجانب التجاري
اللي في ذيك اللحظة، لاحظنا أنه بدأ يؤثر على العلاقة العائليّة
لذلك الوالد والعم أخذوا قرار مصيري، قالوا: مادام وصلنا لهذه المرحلة
خلونا نحافظ على العلاقة العائليّة، ونفصل العمل
وهذا اللي زي ما تفضلت
كثير من العوائل توصل لهذه المرحلة للأسف
وهذا يمكن أبو خالد هنا نوقف شوية قبلما نكمل القصة
ونفتح سالفة أسباب فشل الشّركات العائليّة
اللي أنا أتذكر أخذت دورة فيها
واطلعت على الأسباب، كان يمكن من أشهر ثلاثة أسباب
رقم واحد: اختلاف رؤية الجيل الثاني مقارنةً مع الأول
الجيل الأول هم بدأوا في ظروف وبيئة، وفرص مختلفة، وأسّسوا
يجي الجيل الثاني عنده رؤية، وفرص، وظروف مختلفة
فيبغى يتجه اتجاه آخر ما يلقى نفسه قادر على هذا الاتجاه
فيحدث الانقسام والاختلاف
فيمكن واحدة من أهم أسباب سقوط الشّركات العائليّة
أن الجيل الثاني يأتي برؤية مختلفة، بس ما يمكّن من تحقيقها
وهذا قد يكون جزء من اللي أنتوا مريتوا فيه
سبب ثاني: هو الدخول المفاجئ للبنات وأبناء البنات
اللي هم عادةً في الشّركات العائليّة مهمّشين، ومُبعدين
ما هو بجزء من العمل التنفيذي، لأن طبيعة الثقافة المحلية
أن اللي يعلمون هم الأبناء وليس البنات، هذا الأصل أو العرف السائد
السبب الثالث: هو أن في كثير من الحالات
يكون النجاح مبني على جهد خارق من المؤسس
سخّر علاقاته وقدراته وإمكانياته
وصنع قصة ممتازة، لكنه لا ينجح في توريث هذه العلاقات
هو ورث أصول وشركات، لكن ما ورث العلاقات
ما ورث الخبرة اللي صنعها أثناء بناءه هذه الشّركة
فهل تقدر تسولف لنا شوي عن أسباب فشل الشّركات العائليّة
سواءً الأسباب هذه أو إذا في أسباب إضافية؟
أنت قلتها، ما شاء الله عليك
الأسباب اللي قلتها 100% فعلًا هي سبب كبير
في سبب قد يكون مهم جدًّا، وهو دخول الأنساب لا تنسى
في الجيل الثاني، والثالث كلمة الأنساب عادةً تكون قوية في القرار
أطراف من خارج العائلة
اللي هم زوجات الأولاد، وأزواج البنات
قضية مهمة جدًّا يمكن عندنا في السّعودية بالذات زي ما تفضلت
دخول المرأة في العمل، وبالذات في منطقتنا في «نجد»
يمكن المنطقة الشرقية والغربية سابقينا بهذا الموضوع
وهذا كان يسبّب إشكال في الشفافية، ووصول المعلومات
مو بس للبنات، لأبناء البنات اللي هم يعتبرون أحيانًا
بعضهم تلقاهم ناجحين في أعمالهم وقادة، لكن ما يحصلون على
وهذا يؤدي إلى أن الالتزام اتجاه الشّركة العائليّة يكون أقل بكثير
وهذه الظروف اللي كانت تحيط بوضع شركتكم
احنا نتكلم على وقتها شركة كانت تحولت إلى بنك، «بنك البلاد» وللا لا؟
اللي هو قطاع الصرافة فقط، هو اللي تم تقييمه
ودخلنا مع عدة صرّافين في ذاك الوقت، وتحول إلى «بنك البلاد»
أما باقي القطاعات ما زلت عائلية
عائلية، أتذكر أنت نقلت لي حوار صار بينك وبين والدك، الله يرحمه
في مسألة الفصل، وذكر مصطلح محدّد أبي أسمعه منك
عطنا كواليس الفصل
الوالد لما جاء موضوع الفصل
كان زي ما قلت لك: اتّخذ القرار على مضض
وكان شايف أن الأمور إذا لم يُتخذ فيها قرار حاسم في ذاك اللحظة
قد تسوء إلى ما هو أسوأ، لكن كانت وصيته لنا أنا وإخواني لما جاء
تكلمنا في أحد الجلسات في موضوع الفصل
قال: أنا ما عندي مانع، لكن أرجوكم رجاء تكونوا مع بعض أنتم وخواتكم
ولازم تشوفون طريقة كيف أن الشّركة هذه تستمر
وكانت نظرته هو لهذا الموضوع أنه فعلًا الاتحاد قوة
ودائمًا لما تتفرق الأسرة تجد الضعيف ينتهي بسرعة
وهذا ما كان يبغاه يصير، كان يبغى
كان يقول: تعلموا من اللي صار لي أنا وأخوي
أنتوا عالجوه بحوكمتكم وترتيباتكم
بالضبط، أنا وأخوي سوينا اللي سويناه
وبنينا الشّركة هذه لسنوات طويلة، والحمد لله نمت وتطورت
فكان يبغى نفس الكلام هذا يستمر مع الجيل الثاني
وتفاجأنا، هذا اللي أنا
تفاجأنا أن عشان يحقق الرؤية
وهذا ما عرفناه إلا بعدما توفى، الله يرحمه
في السنوات الأخيرة لما كان مريض، كان ندخل عليه في غرفته أحيانًا
وهو على السرير وكذا
أدخل عليه أنا أحيانًا لحالي، والبنات لحالهم، وإخواني لحال
إذا صرنا لحالنا يوصيني أنا على البنات
يقول: انتبهوا، عبدالعزيز انتبه لخواتك
وتفاجأنا أن لما تدخل البنت عليه في الغرفة لحاله
لا تتركين إخوانك، خليك معهم
فشوف كيف رؤيته كان له نظرة، كان يستخدم كل الأدوات هذه لإنجاحها
وهذا أنا أتصور، أرجع لنقطتي اللي قلت لك: أنا كيف دور البنات
كان في النجاح اللي وصلنا له
أتوقع هذه اللحظات والكلمات الحاسمة من الوالد كان لها دور
في شخصية مهمة في هذه المرحلة، وأنت ذكرته بإشادة، ويستاهل
الشيخ «سليمان الراجحي» أيش كان دوره في المرحلة هذه؟
والله الشيخ «سليمان» العم، الله يطول عمره ويحفظه
الوالد أول ما جاء له رفض الفكرة
وكان الأخ «ناصر» قال له: أبدًا شوفوا حل
مش ممكن يكون الفصل هو الحل، ففي الأخير الأخ «ناصر»
كان عضو مجلس إدارة في «مصرف الراجحي» قبل
وتعرف على علاقة بالعم «سليمان»
والعم «سليمان» كان يعتبر الوالد بمثابة أخ وأب في بعض الأحيان
وكان تعرف له قصص كثيرة مع الوالد
وفي أحد زياراته للوالد طرح هو، فتح
كان يسمع عن بعض التحديات اللي كانت موجودة
فسأل «ناصر» أخوي، قال له: ليش ما فكرتوا في موضوع الفصل وكذا؟
قال له: والله احنا طرحنا الموضوع على الوالد، ورفض
فالله يجزاه الخير، قال: لا أنا اللي بجي أكلمه
وجاء فعلًا عند الوالد، وحكى له: قصة فصلهم هو وإخوانه
وكيف أن الأمور مشت بشكل طبيعي، والحمد لله تطورت
والعلاقة العائليّة استمرت
فكان له، الله يجزاه خير، دور كبير في إقناع الوالد في هذا الموضوع
لما جيتوا للحظة تنفيذ الفصل، كان عند والدك توصية في طريقة الفصل
قال: أبيها مثل
مثل قسمة البطيخ، أبدًا أنا ما عندي مانع
صحيح، الوالد لما جاء وقت الفصل، قال: أنا ما عندي مانع
وهذه كانت توصيته «لناصر» لأن احنا اخترنا الأخ «ناصر»
هو اللي يكون ممثلنا في عملية الفصل، فكان أوصى لأخوي «ناصر»
قال له: ما عندي مانع في الفصل، لكن أبغاها تكون قسمة بطيخ
تعرف مصطلح قسمة بطيخ عندنا فيها
المقصود فيها أنك لا تركز على حجم البطيخ
خلاص وحدة ووحدة، لا تفصل وتركز وكذا
خلّكم سمحين
سمحين في الإجراءات
كم أخذ منكم الموضوع؟
والله ما أخذ أعتقد ثلاثة شهور، وكان كل شيء منتهى وموقع
وتم بطريقة جدًّا جميلة، تخيل أن مثلًا الإجراء اللي تم
وتشكلت لجنة، وفيها ممثل من كل طرف، وكان في اثنين مستقلين
واتفقوا على أن كل واحد
أول شيء يحصرون الأصول، والثروة بكل بنودها في الميزانيات
أنا قلت لك: كنا كل واحد كان مسؤول عن شيء
ما كنا نعرف الشيء اللي عند الطرف الآخر، وهم ما يعرفون اللي عندنا
وكان في شوية، خلني أقول: نقص في موضوع الشفافية
فقلنا: خلنا نحصر كل شيء الثروة، وحصرناها
بعدين طُلب من كل طرف، أن يقدم أيش الأشياء اللي يرغب يحتفظ فيها
وهذه تكون بظرف مسكر، وتم تكليف الأعضاء المستقلين
بأنهم يشوفون الأشياء اللي كُل طرف يرغب في الاحتفاظ فيها
كل شيء مُقيّم
فكل الأشياء اللي رغب فيها عائلة «محمد السبيعي» أخذ
وما طلبوها عائلة «عبد الله» أخذوها عائلة «محمد»
وكل الأشياء اللي طلبوها عائلة «عبد الله» وما طلبوها عائلة «محمد»
أخذوها عائلة «عبد الله» آسف، والأشياء اللي طُلبت من الطرفين
بالقرعة، شفت كيف الإجراء؟ وخلاص يلا أنت خذ هذا وخذ هذا
والأشياء اللي ما طُلبت، هذه كانت هي المرجّح
خلاص أنت خذ هذه اللي ما طلبت، أنت ناقص عن
تقييم كذا ناقص عن كذا، فهذه اللي ما طُلبت، خذها
ونفس الشيء سووها طرف «محمد» وتم توقيع
ثلاثة شهور، وأنتوا خالصين
ثلاثة شهور، منتهيين
ويمكن يحسب لكم ويؤكد على سماحة
وصفاء النفوس في تلك المرحلة
أن ما أحد درى
صحيح
لا شفنا في إعلام، وللا صحف، وللا في أي محاكم
ولا شفنا في أي احنا أقصد كمجتمع ما سمعنا إلا أن تم الفصل
هذه أحد القيم الأساسية لما أقول لك: أن الوالد ما يحب الإعلام
في اللحظة هذه، أنا متأكد لو كان الملف الإعلامي عالي كان الكل درى
والكل تدخل، وكتب، وأثّر على تفكير
ولو من أفراد العائلة أحد خالف هذه السياسة
وللا عنده هوس الضجيج، والحضور الإعلامي كان ممكن سوّى شوشرة
100%
لأن تحتاج بس واحد أهبل، ويشوّه سمعة العائلة كلها
أعز الله صدقت
بعد هذه اللحظة اللي هي تقريبًا 2010 أو 2011
صح 2010
بدأتوا أنتوا رحلتكم في موضوع الحوكمة والمّأسسة
واللي هي لُب حلقتنا اليوم
فمن وين بدأت أبو خالد؟
أيش أول خطوة في حوكمة الشّركات العائليّة؟
والله شوف احنا بدأنا البداية الحقيقية كانت قبل الفصل
بكل أمانة كان الوالد والعم وعيال العم والإخوان
يحسّون بالضغط، وأننا نحتاج إلى تنظيم
أنا قلت لك: العلاقات، وطريقة الشغل كيف كانت
فبحثنا، ولقينا في دورة في جامعة «إنسياد» في «سنغافورة»
يتكلم عن تنظيم الشّركات العائليّة، وكان اليوم في بروفيسور أمريكي
وكان يتكلم عن الكثير من التجارب
في الشّركات الأمريكية واليابانية والصينية
وبعض الشّركات من المنطقة هنا اللي لها 200 و300 سنة
وهي تنتقل من جيل إلى جيل، وشركات مُنظّمة، وعملها ناجح
ورحنا حضرت الدورة هذه أنا، واثنين من عيال عمي
وفعلًا كان بالنسبة لي أنا شخصيًا فتح
زي ما تفضلت، موضوع تنظيم الشّركات العائليّة صندوق أسود
يحتاج إلى تعمّق، وفهم
ويحتاج إلى أنك تفصّله على الأشياء اللي تناسب، واللي لا
فكانت هذه أول مبادرة أو بادرة اللي ساعدتنا كثير في أننا نفهم
أساسًا أيش هو الشّركة العائليّة، وكيف تتنظّم، الأساسيات
فبعدها لما رجعنا من الدورة هذه
شاركنا الكلام هذا مع الإخوان، وعيال العم
وأثنوا على أن فعلًا الكلام اللي سمعوه
قالوا: ليش ما نجيب البروفيسور يعطينا يوم كامل ورشة عمل
ونتكلم فيه عن الحالة حقنا، أيش نسوي
دعينا البروفيسور «كارلوك» الله يذكره بالخير، وجاء
سوينا ورشة عمل في «جدة» يوم كامل، وغصنا في دهاليز
لما كانت شركة «محمد وعبدالله إبراهيم السبيعي»
فكانت هذه البداية، وهنا بنيت القناعة عند الجميع بأن نحتاج إلى تنظيم
لسّه ما نعرف أيش التنظيم، ولا أيش بنسوي، لكن هنا التنظيم
جاءت مرحلة الفصل اللي هو 2010، وما كملنا الرحلة
بعد 2010 بكل أمانة، تحقيقًا لرغبة الوالد اللي ذكرت لك إيّاها قبل شوي
ولرغبة الإخوان والخوات كلهم
شكلنا لجنة
واشتغلنا ورش عمل مطولة كانت مع أحد المكاتب الاستشارية
والبداية هي في الميثاق العائلي
أبو عبد الرحمن اليوم تعرف أنت في الشّركات في دائرتين
دائرة الملكيّة، ودائرة العمل التنفيذي أو الإداري
الدائرتين هذه متقاطعة بشكل جزئي
ودائرة الملكيّة عادةً اللي يحكمها نظام وزارة التجارة، وهيئة سوق المال
الأنظمة القضائية، الأنظمة العليا في أي دولة
والمرجع فيها عادةً لمؤسسات حكومية
دائرة التنفيذ اللي يحكمها نظام الحوكمة
والسياسات والإجراءات في الشّركات
هو مرجعها عادةً الجمعية العمومية في الشّركة
والشّركات العائليّة دائرة ثالثة تجي، وتتقاطع مع الدائرتين هذه
وتسبب تعقيد أكبر وأكبر، اللي دائرة العائلة
دائرة العائلة أيش يحكمها؟
عادةً مجموعة قيم غير مكتوبة، هذا اللي يحكمها
مرجعها هو عادةً المؤسس أو كبير العائلة
فإذا ما كُتبت ونُظّمت هذه الدائرة، وعلاقتها بدائرة الملكيّة، والتنفيذ
هنا تبدأ نقاط التّماس، والتّحسس والمشاكل
فاللي ينظم دائرة العائلة يا أبو عبد الرحمن هو الميثاق العائلي
وأتذكر هنا أبو خالد قبلما ندخل في موضوع الميثاق
البروفيسور اللي دعيتوه سألكم سؤال
قال: أنتم موجودين عشان تخدمون الشّركة، وللا العكس؟
هذا كان سؤال جوهري، وأعتقد
هذه كانت البداية؟
البدايات، وهذا سؤال يُفترض أن يسأل لكل شركة عائلية تبغى التنظيم
هذا الكلام كان في ورش العمل
وكان من ضمن الأشياء اللي اتفقت عليها كل العائلة
هل العائلة موجودة لدعم الشّركة العائليّة، أم العكس؟
وكان يشرح، يقول: إذا أنتوا تبون تصنعون عمل عائلي
فيجب على العائلة أن تدعم الشّركة العائليّة
أما إذا كنتوا تبغون تصنعون جمعية خيريّة
فالشّركة العائليّة هي اللي تدعم العائلة
فكان اختيار بالإجماع أن لا، العائلة موجودة لدعم الشّركة العائليّة
وهذا لا يعني أن الشّركة العائليّة لا تعطي فوائد، ودعم للعائلة
ولكن دعم منظم ومحوكم، ويأخذ في الاعتبار المصلحة العليا
ويأخذ في الاعتبار الأهداف طويلة الأمد، وأشياء أخرى
وهذا اللي الحمد لله الشّركات العائليّة الناجحة اليوم تتمتع فيه
فأول خطوة كانت هي إعداد الميثاق
وأنتوا أعديتوا ميثاقكم الأول، وأُعتمد في 2015
نعم
أكرمتني بنسخة منه، واللي أعجبني فيها
واللي قد يبدو للناس نقطة ضعف، أنا أشوفها قوة
أن الميثاق كان بسيط، وما هو معقد
مباشر، ولا فيه، ما شفت أشياء مبهرة
ما شفت الأشياء اللي بقول: واو كيف سويتوها، مرة مبسّط
فالسياسة كانت خلونا نبدأ بهذه النقطة، ونطور لاحقًا
خلونا نوثق اللي متفقين عليه مبدئيًا، ونحسنه ونطوّره لاحقًا
فكتب الميثاق بمجموعة أركان فيها تعريفات
فيها طريقة التخارج، وحل النزاعات، وطريقة الإدارة
فيها هل الأبناء يكونون في الفريق التنفيذي، وللا لا؟
غطّى أغلب الأسئلة اللي عادةً ينتج عنها مشكلة إذا لم تغطّى، أو تكتب
فعطنى كواليس كتابة الميثاق
وأيش توصيتك اليوم للشركات اللي ما عندها ميثاق عائلي
أيش أفضل طريقة أنهم ينجزون هذا الأمر؟
سر النجاح دائمًا يا أبو عبد الرحمن، وأنت أدري وأنت، ما شاء الله عليك
في البساطة
اليوم كلما كنت بسيط، وواضح ومباشر
كان نجاحك أسهل، وأوضح وأسرع
وزي ما تفضلت الهدف من الميثاق العائلي هو معالجة
خلني أقول: نقاط التماس الأساسية اللي عادةً تنتج عنها مشاكل
أول نقطة تماس يمكن هي موضوع الملكيّة والتملك، وكيف التملك
وكل القضايا اللي لها علاقة بالملكيّة، وهذا كان واضح في الميثاق
النقطة الثانية: طريقة اختيار مجلس الإدارة، والإدارة التنفيذية
وكلما يتعلق بالإدارة
النقطة الثالثة: القرارات المتعلقة بتوزيع الأرباح، وبالجمعية العمومية
والنقطة الرابعة: قضايا النزاعات، والخلافات لو نشأت
وكيف تعالج، ويتم الإجراءات في معالجتها
هذه هي أهم أربع قضايا في أي ميثاق عائلي
خلنا نأخذهم وحدة وحدة
في بعض العوائل يضيفون أشياء ثانية
احنا ما رأينا أننا نروح على قولتهم لهذه المنطقة
لأن فعلًا نبغى نترك الحرية بكل أمانة لأفراد العائلة
أنهم يأخذون قرارات قد لا تكون مؤثرة بشكل كبير على العمل العائلي
وخصوصًا أن احنا أخذنا قرار مصيري يا أبو عبد الرحمن
وكثير من العوائل إذا جلست تتكلم معهم
يقولون: أنتم كيف أخذتوا هذا القرار؟
وأيش تأثيراته على أبناء جيل المستقبل؟
والقرار اللي أخذناه أن فصل الملكيّة عن الإدارة بشكل كامل
وأن أبناء العائلة لا يعملون في العمل التنفيذي
وهذه ودي أركّز عليها، وأفصل فيها إذا تسمح لي شوي
عطنا ياريت
قلت لك: أنا يمكن هذا ناتج عن مشاكل العهد السابق
اللي كنا بدأنا نحسها
وكنت قلت لك: هو كان سبب يمكن أساسي في الفصل
أن كنا كلنا داخلين في العمل
أنتم وعيال عمكم؟
احنا وعيال عمنا نعم
فالقرار اللي اتخذ لا يعني عدم دخول الأبناء في
أو جيل المستقبل أو احنا كجيل ثاني في العمل العائلي
ولكن دخولنا يكون فقط عن طريق مجالس الإدارة
وكل شخص يرغب في ترشيح نفسه لمجلس الإدارة
يجب أن يخضع لمعايير معين، ويحقّق عدّة معايير مذكورة في الميثاق
وعندنا مجلس إدارة الشّركة القابضة، أو الشّركة العائليّة
وعندنا مجالس إدارات في الشّركات التّابعة
يُمكن لأي فرد من أفراد العائلة
أن يرشّح نفسه بتوصية من مجلس إدارة الشّركة القابضة
بشروط معينة
ليش ممنوع تكون في الإدارة التنفيذية؟
وأنا أعرف بعض الأصدقاء، أصدقائي من أبناء العائلة
وأعرف قديش هم أصحاب كفاءة عالية
محترفين
ويشتغلون في «جي بي مورقان» وفي «كريدي سويس»
وحتى في منظمات دولية ما هو بس محلية
ليش تخسرون هذه الكفاءات؟
ليش أنتوا قفّلتوا هذا الباب، أيش شايفين؟
احنا ما خسرناها، هذا المصطلح اللي أنا ما ودّي أن الناس تنظر له
بالعكس احنا استفدنا منها، اليوم
على مستوى مجلس الإدارة
مجلس الإدارة واللجان
أنا أبغى أفهم ليش ما تبغونهم في الإدارة التنفيذية؟
لأن أبو عبدالرحمن من يوم ما يدخل أحد من العائلة
أولًا لن تستطيع استقطاب كفاءات إدارية مستقلة
اليوم أحد أهم النجاحات اللي حقّقتها «ماسك»
هو قدرتها على استقطاب كفاءات
أنا، وكل المساهمين فخورين
بأن يكونوا موجودين عندنا كفاءات بحجمهم، وما هو كذا بس
الرؤساء التنفيذيين اللي قدرنا نستقطبهم، ومدراء الإدارات
يعيشون في بيئة، وخلق هذا الموضوع بيئة احترافية
وبيئة مأسساتية 100%
أنت تعرف يا أبو عبدالرحمن مهما كان دخول ابن من أبناء المؤسسين
معك في الإدارة، ويشتغل معك فيها، وفي الليل
عارف أنه يتعشى عند أبوه بسولف، والله اليوم صار كذا، وفلان قال كذا
مهما كان هذا كل شيء طبيعي، ويصير بأثر على
لأني أدري ما راح يكون لي أنا طموح أني أقود هذه الشّركة
لأن جنبي ولد راعي الحلال، أكيد المنصب مجهز له، وهو الأولى
بالضبط، غير قضايا المنافسة والتنافس اللي يصير بين أبناء العائلة
على هذا المنصب، وللا المكان، واللي قد يكون له تأثيرات كثيرة
يمكن هذه نجحت معكم أبو خالد في أن، أنا مبهور
وهذه نادرة في الشّركات العائليّة
من مستوى الكفاءات اللي استقطبتوها
الحمد لله
نذكر مع التقدير للجميع مثلًا معالي الأستاذ «أحمد الخطيب»
كان قبلما يكون وزير، هو كان معكم في تأسيس
وقيادة شركة «جدوى»
إلى أن تم اختياره مستشار في ديوان سمو ولي العهد
الأمير «سلمان» آنذاك
في عام 2014 أو 2013، وأول رئيس تنفيذي لشركة «ماسك»
هو معالي «إحسان بافقيه»
اللي هو لاحقًا أُختير كرئيس لهيئة عقارات الدولة
اليوم اللي يقود «ماسك» هو «هاني حلواني»
أنتوا سويتوا المستحيل على فكرة
اليوم كل القطاع الخاص يتشكى من «صندوق الاستثمارات العامة»
أنهم ياخذون الكافاءت
أنتوا أول ناس أخذتوا من «صندوق الاستثمارات العامة» كفاءات
أخذتوا «هاني» من «صندوق الاستثمارات العامة»
الحمدلله
وهو اليوم يقود شركة «ماسك»
صحيح
ففعلًا سالفة أن عدم وجود أبناء العائلة في الإدارة التنفيذية
أتاح الفرصة أنك تستقطب كفاءات بهذا المستوى
100% والحمد لله، زي ما تفضلت
معالي «أحمد الخطيب» كان المستشار في تأسيس «ماسك»
لأن كان هو الرئيس التنفيذي في شركة «جدوى للاستثمار»
وهي شركة مستقلة عن «ماسك»
بس أنتوا المستثمر أو المالك الأكبر فيها؟
صحيح، احنا في شركة «جدوى» وفي «بنك البلاد» المستثمر الأكبر
وزي ما تفضلت معالي «إحسان بافقيه» كان له دور كبير
في الفترة الانتقالية الأولى، والتأسيس
ويعتبر فرد من أفراد العائلة بكل أمانة
وعاصر الوالد، الله يرحمه، وسمع منه أشياء كثيرة
واليوم أنا فخور جدًّا بوجود رئيس تنفيذي مثل الأخ «هاني حلواني»
على رأس الهرم التنفيذي في شركة «ماسك»
وأعتقد السبب الأول لقدرتنا على بناء بيئة جاذبة بهذا الشكل
يا أبو عبدالرحمن
وأقولها، وبدون تردد هو خروجه أبناء العائلة من العمل التنفيذي اليومي
وليس خروج أبناء العائلة، وتخليهم عن الشّركة
هذا فرق كبير يجب أن يُفهم في الشّركات العائليّة
مثلًا خليني أتحدى شوي الفكرة هذه أبو خالد
وأقول لك: في عوائل أخرى مثلًا من العوائل الناجحة
واللي عندهم تجربة تستحق الاحترام، عائلة «الزامل»
صحيح
وعائلة «الزامل» العكس، أبناء العائلة موجودين
وعندهم سياسة أن أول خمس سنوات لازم تعمل برة الشّركة العائليّة
بعدين إذا أثبتت نفسك برة، الله يحييك، تعال، وابدأ في السلم
وعندهم أظن قانون أنك ما تعمل تحت القطاع اللي يقوده أبوك
أو أحد من نفس الفرع حق العائلة
فتجد فلسفتهم أن «ما حك جلدك مثل ظفرك»
ما حد بيكون أحرص على الحلال من أصحابه
فهم بالعكس يحفّزون أبناء العائلة، روح اكسب خبرة، وتعال اشتغل معانا
لأن ما أحد أحرص على الحلال منك أنت
فكيف تشوف النموذج هذا؟
والله يا أخي عائلة «الزامل» جايين من المريخ الظاهر
ما أعرف أنا ما أدري شلون
ما شاء الله عليهم
الله يحفظهم، تراهم من أقرب الناس للعائلة
فعلًا نموذجهم، أنا شخصيًا تسألني، أقول: أنا مالي عارف كيف نجح
بس في ثقافة عالية جدًّا بين أفراد العائلة في مجموعة «الزامل»
في قضية كيف التعامل في حالات الخلافات والشد
شيء ما أدري هو سحر! ما أدري والله اسألهم
احنا ناس طبيعيين، هم مو بطبيعيين
الطبيعي أن تطلع أبناء العائلة من القضية
الطبيعي أن أي نقاش يتم، ويكون فيه شد لا بد يترك أثر، مع الزمن يكبر
«الزامل» مو بطبيعيين، أنا ما أدري أيش بيسوون
علّمني بس أيش يشربون، ويأكلون
في أول عنصر تسولفنا عنه الآن في موضوع ميثاق العائلة
أنكم منعتوا أبناء الأسرة بكاملهم من العمل التنفيذي اليومي
وركّزتوا وجودهم في مجالس الإدارة
اللي هو العمل الاستراتيجي طويل المدى
نعم، مجالس الإدارة واللجان، ومجالس إدارات الشّركات
هذه عدد كبير من المناصب، ويحتاج إلى تخصصات كثيرة
ويحتاج إلى التزام كبير، ودعم
ودام تكلمت عن هذا الجزء، خليني أشوف أطرح فيه مجموعة أسئلة
لا، إذا تسمح لي بعطيك أيش اللي صار عندنا، وفأجاني أنا شخصيًا
ياليت
وإذا تسمح لي عاد هذا، الله يستر، ما يزعلون علي بس إخواني وخواتي
لا، إن شاء الله، للمصلحة العامة، فجازهم الله خير
وخلني أخذ أيش اللي صار عندنا في جيل المستقبل
وأمسك كل واحد من، أبي أستبعد إذا تسمح لي العيال
لأن العيال وأبناؤهم، قلت لك: أنا «وإبراهيم وناصر»
أولادنا دائمًا تعرف نسولف عليهم في العمل التجاري وكذا، وندخلهم
فأمورهم، الحمد لله، كلهم ماشيين على طريق العمل التجاري وكذا
لكن شوف اللي صار في جانب البنات
أختي «لولوة» الكبير، الله يحفظها، ويطول عمرها
صار عندها حفيدات، سووا فكرة اسمه «مليح» قبل نحو شهر
ونجح نجاح باهر، وهو فكرة عبارة عن أزياء وإكسسوارات
وأبدعوا في هذا المجال، وضموا خواتهم وإخوانهم معهم في العمل
هذا بالإضافة إلى أن بعض الأبناء وصلوا لوظائف كبيرة في البنوك
وفي المؤسسات المالية، أبنائها وأحفادها
نمسك أختي «هدى» ما شاء الله، صار عندها حفيدات
تخصصوا في مجالات معينة في التصميم
وبدأوا يأسّسون مكاتب، وشركات في التصميم
وأبنائها الآن بدأوا يأسسون شركات استثمارية
تكرر وترسّخ، وتعيد تجربة «ماسك»
أختي «هيفاء» أم عبد الرحمن، ويزيد أصحابك، ما شاء الله تبارك الله
تقلدوا مناصب كبيرة، وأخذوا طريقهم في العمل في القطاع الخاص
في مؤسسات مرموقة في العالم، وما شاء الله تبارك الله
وصلوا لمراحل متقدمة، والآن بدأوا يأسسون شركة استثمارية خاصة فيهم
وكلهم هذول اللي أتكلم عنهم ما زالوا معنا في «ماسك»
وفي مجالس الإدارة والشّركات
أختي «وفاء» واحد من أبنائها، ما شاء الله، منصب كبير
في أحد القطاعات الحكومية المرتبطة بالرؤية
هيئة التصنيع العسكري «قامي»
وما شاء الله تبارك الله، أبدع في هذا المجال
وعلى فكرة هو كان في فترة من الفترات
عضو مجلس إدارة معنا في «ماسك»
أختي «مها» ما شاء الله، عيالها دخلوا في قطاع المطاعم، والتصميم
ووحدة من بناتها، ما شاء الله تبارك الله، صارت متخصصة
في تصميم تجهيزات المطاعم، وأبدعت في هذا المجال
والآن عندها سيرة طويلة على قولتهم في الشّركة حقتها
الأخت «ندى»
أحد أبنائها كان موظف في أحد البنوك، ووصل لمراحل جدًّا متقدمة
مو بـ«بنك البلاد»
لا، ممنوع
ممنوع يعملون في «بنك البلاد»؟
لا، احنا دائمًا ما نقبل
هذا أحد المعايير اللي قلت لك: موجودة في الميثاق
ما نقبل أن يعمل في عمل له علاقة في «ماسك»
هذه السنوات اللي يعملها في أي شركة من الشّركات
اللي «ماسك» مستثمرة فيها ما نعتبرها من ضمن سنوات الخبرة
ما تحسب
فالآن ما شاء الله، ابنها «مشعل الموسى» هذا أختي «ندى»
يحضًر الماجستير، وبدأ يؤسس شركة استثمارية عقارية
وما شاء الله، أبدع في بعض الفكر، والمنتجات اللي بدأ يسويها
وعلى فكرة قبل ثلاثة أيام «مشعل» عرض تجربة «ماسك»
في مشروع التخرج في الماجستير
يدرس في جامعة مرموقة في بريطانيا
وكان بقية الطلبة عرضوا نماذج من مختلف العالم
وأبشرك نموذج «ماسك» هو اللي أخذ تقريبًا أعلى الدرجات في البرنامج
ففعلًا كان الحمد لله شهادة نعتز فيها، وهذا الكلام قبل يومين
لو أقول لك: مثلًا حفيدات أخوي «إبراهيم» شوف البنات
أسّسوا شركة في صناعة الهوية
الآن دخلها فوق الستين أو سبعين مليون في السنة، وقِس
فأقول لك: انتشر في
لما سوينا هذا الكلام بدل ما يكونوا كل الناس معتمدين على «ماسك»
وكل أبناء جيل المستقبل معتمدين على «ماسك»
وينظرون، ويبحثون عن فرص وظيفية لـ «ماسك»
صاروا ينظرون لأنفسهم، أيش أقدر أسوي؟
وكيف أصنع قصة نجاح لنفسي؟
فهذا المكسب أنهم ما علموا في الشّركة العائليّة
هم أثبتوا نفسهم في مواقع أخرى بدعم من الشّركة العائليّة
مذهلة، تبي الصدق؟ ما كان في دور للشركة العائليّة في هذا الموضوع
ما كان في دور يُذكر
يمكن ساهمت الشّركة العالية في أول وظيفة، توصية
توجيه أو دورة معينة مثلًا الشّركة العائليّة كان
بس هو الشاهد هنا بأن لو كلهم موجودين في الشّركة العائليّة
يمكن ما طلعت قدراتهم بالشكل هذا
وقصص النجاح هذه اللي نشوفها ما كان طلعت
وهنا بستكمل هذه يا أبو خالد، وأقول لك: في موضوع مجالس الإدارة
أنتم عندكم شرط وجود أعضاء مستقلين
أظن ثلاثة من المقاعد، أنتوا تسعة أعضاء؟
نعم، احنا مجلس إدارة تسعة أعضاء
ثلاثة منهم لازم يكونون مستقلين
نعم
اشرح لنا مفهوم الأعضاء المستقلين
الدور الرئيسي لأعضاء المستقلين هو نقل تجارب
وتحدي بعض القواعد الأساسية الروتينية
اللي تعودت العائلة على أنها تعمل بها
وهذا تعرف الآن صار من أفضل الممارسات العالمية
ما هو بس عندنا في «ماسك»
أعتقد هيئة سوق المال تفرض هذا الموضوع
ووزارة التجارة تنصح كثير بهذا الموضوع
ووجود كفاءات مستقلة، تفكيرها يكون مستقل
وخارج العائلة في أي مجلس إدارة
يعطي عدة فوائد، الفائدة الأولى: يكون صوت مرجّح
في حالة صار في عدة آراء في أعضاء مجلس الإدارة من عائلة وحدة
الفائدة الثانية: يعطيك رأي مستقل في اللي تقوله الإدارة التنفيذية
ورأي قد يكون مشبّع بخبرات وتجارب
خارج التجارب اللي العائلة تعمل فيها
هذا بخلاف الثالث اللي هو فعلًا تنوع الخبرات اللي تستقطبها
اليوم إذا عندك مجلس إدارة معظمه مثلًا استثماريين
وأنت تخطط تدخل في القطاع الطبي
مثلًا تستقطب أحد عنده التجربة هذه
أنت تبغى تدخل في قطاع السّياحة
والعائلة تاريخيًّا ما كان عندها خبرات في السياحة
أنت تستقطب أحد في هذا المجال، وهكذا
بكل أمانة تجربتنا في «ماسك» في دخول الأعضاء المستقلين
كانت تجربة رائعة جدًّا ومفيدة
ويمكن برضو امتداد لموضوع الإدارة، وعلاقة العائلة بها
أسولف أنا مع «هاني حلواني» رئيس شركة «ماسك»
وقال لي: أول ما جيت استغربت بأن، توقعت هذه ترتيبات عائلية
اجتمعوا، وقالوا: هذه أسمائنا، وهذا اللوح
مثلما يحدث في أغلب الشّركات العائليّة
يقول: ذهلت أن الثلاث مقاعد المخصصة لجيل المستقبل
يتنافس عليها تسعة من أبناء الأسرة
ففي منافسة، وسباق على هذا المقعد
ما هو بشيء مطبوخ، ومرتب ويتنفذ
هذه قصة نفتخر فيها، والله يا أبو عبدالرحمن
واللي فازوا في النهاية ما هم بأبناء الأبناء
من أصل ثلاثة، اثنين أبناء البنات، وبنت وحدة
فصوتوا المساهمين فعلًا
فاشرح لنا كيف موضوع علاقة المجالس هذه بالعائلة
أقصد اشتراطات الترشيح، وطريقة التنافس
أنتوا كنتوا حاطين ثلاثة مقاعد محفوظة مخصصة لكم الجيل الثاني
الحين ألغيتوها صارت ستة مقاعد
ستة المقاعد الآن صارت ممثلة للعائلة
وصار في تشجيع كبير من دخول أبناء جيل المستقبل في مجالس الإدارات
وهنا التوازن اللي نتكلم عنه أبو عبد الرحمن
احنا نشترط مثلًا شهادة جامعيّة
ومجموعة قيم نشترطها قبل أنها تكون متناسبة مع قيم العائلة
ورؤية الشّركة العائليّة، هذه اشتراطات
وزي ما قلت لك: خمس سنوات خبرة في شركة مستقلة
بعيدة عن «ماسك» وشركة لازم تكون من الشّركات المعتبرة
بنظرة مجلس الإدارة، وجمعية المساهمين
وأن يحقق ترقيتين على الأقل خلال الخمس سنوات
وفي تفاصيل أخرى يمكن موجودة ومكتوبة في الميثاق
وهذا اللي يخلي المرشح يستطيع أن يرشّح نفسه
لأي مقعد من مقاعد مجلس الإدارة
وتصويت من جميع أعضاء الجمعية العموميّة
وأنا أقول لك: اللي صعق «هاني» وخلّاه
وهذا الشيء فخورين فيه، أنا أذكره لأنه كثير أحيانًا تُكتب أفضل
عوائل كثيرة كتبت مواثيق كثيرة، لما يجي التطبيق
تجي أبغى أستثني هذا وأسوي هذا، وهذا ما أقدر ألتزم فيه
وأتنازل عن هذا
هذه مشكلة كبيرة في الشّركات العائليّة
أن يُجاب مستشارين، وتعقد ورش عمل، ويُكتب مواثيق
لكن التحدي يجي عند التنفيذ أبو عبد الرحمن
100%
وهذا اللي احنا استطعنا أن نتجاوزه
والمثال، والقصة اللي ذكرتها فخورين فيها
اللي ترشحوا أكثر من تسعة
ولكن في مراجعة بعض المعايير والاشتراطات
تم استبعاد بعضهم، والتسعة تم ترشيحهم
وزي ما ذكرت تم التصويت لثلاثة مقاعد
التصويت كان زي أي تصويت في أي جمعية عمومية بشركة مساهمة
تصويت سرّي
كل مساهم ممكن يختار العضو اللي يشوفه مناسب والأصلح
بدون ضغوطات اجتماعية
وللا يقول: لا يزعل علي أخوي، وللا أختي، وللا
كان التصويت بهذا الشكل، وتم اختيار ابنين من بنت وحدة
وهذا الشيء «هاني» واحنا كنا نفتخر فيه
يمكن هذا كله جزء مرتبط بموضوع الإدارة، وقد نرجع لها في وقت لاحق
لكن أبغى أروح الحين لموضوع الملكيّة
لفت نظري، وأنا أقرأ الميثاق أنكم اشترطوا كل الوَرثة أو الملّاك
أنهم ما يكونوا يملكون باسمهم كأفراد، كل واحد حوّل حصّته إلى شركة
ففي شركة اسمها شركة «عبد العزيز بن محمد السبيعي»
هي اللي تملك في «ماسك»
ليش ممنوع الأفراد، والأوقاف يملكون في «ماسك»؟
هذا موضوع جدًّا مهم، وفي ممارسات، وخيارات كثيرة
وهنا لازم أشيد بنظام الشّركات السّعودي الجديد اللي طُرح
وحرص معالي الوزير الدكتور «ماجد القصبي»
وسماعه لكثير من ملاحظات الشّركات العائليّة
أنا من خلال دوري في المركز الوطني للمنشآت العائليّة
كان لنا دور كبير في صياغة نظام الشّركات السّعودي الجديد
وأنا أزعم بأن، الحمد لله، صار عندنا نظام شركات، بإذن الله
أنه من أفضل عشر أنظمة في العالم، وخصوصًا من ناحية المرونة
ومن ناحية استيعابه لمتطلبات الشّركات العائليّة
ويبقى قضية التنفيذ الآن، واللوائح التنفيذية، والعمل عليها
لكن كنظام عام أعتقد نظام الشّركات السّعودي الجديد
نظام راعي، وداعم كبير للشركات العائليّة
احنا لما فكّرنا في هذا الهيكل كان بالنظام القديم
ولكني أعتقد أن هيكل مناسب حتى في النظام الجديد
لسبب ثقافي يمكن أكثر، وله علاقة بالسّعودية
احنا عندنا الشّركة القابضة، اللي هي «ماسك»
الملكيّة فيها في شركات ذات مسؤولية محدودة
ونفكر الحين نحولها لشركات مساهمة مبسّطة حسب النظام الجديد
وهذا مصطلح وشركة نوع من أنواع الشّركات
اللي مو موجود في كل دول العالم
علشان نحمي الشّركة من الورثة في المستقبل
لا سمح الله، صار أي خلاف بين أبنائي أو أبناء أي مساهم آخر
في المستقبل في أي موضوع
ففي الشّركات هذه طبقة عازلة بين الخلافات اللي تصير فوق وبين
فاللي كان يصير أول بأن لو مثلًا عمر يملك في هذه الشّركة
لو انتقلت حصّة عمر إلى أبنائه، وللا ورثته
فجأة أنتوا تلاقون بدل ما مالك، صار عندكم سبعة ملّاك
بالضبط
بدال ما تأخذ القرار من شخص واحد، صرت تأخذه من سبعة
ولو هذول السبعة اختلفوا، عطلوا مصالح الشّركة
الحمدلله، لأن الشّركة مساهمة مُقفلة ما تتعطل
بس بتسوي شوشرة، وعدم راحة خلني أقول، خلق بيئة غير صحية
ولكن، إن شاء الله
الآن «عمر» ومشاكله كلها صارت محفوظة في هذه الشركة
في شركته، بالضبط
وقبيلكم مع «عمر» هو مدير هذه الشّركة
ممثل
ممثل الشّركة هذه
الممثل في جمعية المساهمين
فمهما صارت تغييرات بين «عمر» وعياله قبيلكم واحد، وممثلهم واحد
100% هذا الهدف الأول
جميل
الهدف الثاني: هو في قضايا البيع والتخارج والرهن
احنا ما نبي يكون كل واحد
عنده أسهم ويروح يرهنا في بنك، ويأخذ مقابلها وكذا
وتتفاجأ بكرة أن في بنك دخل شريك معك
فهذه طبقة عازلة أنت لك حق تتصرف في أسهمك اللي فوق
بس الأسهم اللي تملك مباشرة في الشّركة العائليّة
وعلى فكرة الشّركات هذه ليس للمساهمين الحق في التصرف فيها
في أي عمل خاص يخصهم
هو الهدف منها فقط تملّك أسهم الشّركة القابضة
اللي هي شركة الأسهم
شركات ذات غرض محدد
وهذه طبّقت، وشايفينها ناجحة
هذه طبّقت، وأنا أنصح فيها بكل قوة في كل الشّركات العائليّة
أنا أشوف أن هذه الطبقة العازلة خلق بيئة..
اجتماعات جمعية المساهمين يا أبو عبد الرحمن تشوفها اليوم
كأنك في أي شركة مدرجة
خلني أتكلم عن موضوع الأوقاف
أنتوا قلتوا: ممنوع الأوقاف تدخل في هذه الشّركة
إي، احنا، وما زلنا إلى اليوم
نظام، أو فكرة الأوقاف بحد ذاتها، مختلفة شوي عن الشّركات العائليّة
فكرة تعتمد على اختلاف يمكن جوهري في الرؤية، ولذلك هي خطيرة
ودخول الأوقاف في الشّركات العائليّة يجب أن يُدرس بشكل معمّق
ومازلنا إلى اليوم، ما وجدنا حل لهذا الموضوع
في بوادر حل، لكن فعلًا دخول الأوقاف بشكل مباشر في أي شركة عائلية
أنا أعتقد أن وصفة لحدوث مشاكل في المستقبل
ليش؟
قلت لك: رؤية الأوقاف تعتمد على توزيع أرباح بشكل أكثر
تعتمد على عدم أخذ مخاطر
نُظّار في الأوقاف دائمًا لابسين طاقية المُدافع
بينما الشّركة العائليّة مهاجمين اللي..
يبغون يعظّمون المنفعة، فيصير في دائمًا إشكاليات في قضايا المخاطر
وأخذ المخاطر
والتوزيعات وكذا، ففي اختلاف جوهري في الرؤية
فلذلك أنا أنصح أن ما يكون دخول الأوقاف مباشر
أُكرر نظام الشّركات الجديد أعطى بوادر كبيرة لحل هذا الموضوع
أحد أهم الأدوات اللي أعطاها هو وجود أسهم متعددة
أسهم ممتازة، وأسهم عادية، ومن خلال استخدامها تحطها بدون تصويت
وأسهم تستحق إلى توزيعات أعلى
وأي شروط تحطها في هذه الأنواع المتعددة من الأسهم
بما يساهم، إن شاء الله، في المستقبل بأنه يحل هذه الإشكالية
احنا منتظرين اليوم اللوائح التنفيذية، ونشوف، إن شاء الله
كيف نستخدم الأدوات هذه في حل مشكلة الأوقاف
بإذن الله، يمكن واحدة من أكبر معضلات الشّركات العائليّة
واللي تؤدي إلى انهيارها، هو موضوع التخارج
هذا ورث انتقل من المؤسس إلى الورثة إلى الأبناء والبنات
واحد منهم ما يبغى يكمل، يبغى يأخذ فلوسه نقدًا ويطلع
فعادةً اللي يصير إما أنهم يجبرونه يقعد، وهذا زي ما أنت تضرب المثال
تقول: إذا سكرت، وقفلت الباب حدّيت الواحد يكسر الزجاج ويطلع
هذا الصحيح
أو أنه يصفي كل الشّركة عشان يأخذ حقوقه أو حصته
كيف تعاملتوا مع موضوع التخارج؟
اللي لاحظت أن هذا فصل واضح في الميثاق
ومكتوبة الآليات، وفي خصم معين
عطنا كيف تعاملتوا مع موضوع التخارج
وفي حال أظن صارت، فلو ممكن تسولف فيها
صحيح، زي ما ذكرت أبو عبدالرحمن
أعتقد التخارج من أهم المسببات اللي تسبب تشنج، وتعطّل أعمال الشّركات العائليّة
وسبب في كثير من الإشكاليات اللي تعاني منها
بطبيعة الإنسان، والبشر يا أبو عبد الرحمن أن تختلف احتياجاته ورغباته
مع اختلافه في السن، والخبرة، والعلاقات بين الأسرة سواءً ذكر أو أنثى
ولا بد أن الشّركات العائليّة، والعوائل يأخذوا هذا في عين الاعتبار في أي تنظيم
أو أي هيكلة تعمل، لأن لو ما أخذتوا في الاعتبار
وسكرت الأبواب، وما صار في طريق واضح للتخارج
وكيف تحصل على قيمة ثروتك، أو مساهمتك راح تسبب مشاكل
وزي ما قلت: إذا الباب مسكر، راح تضطر تكسر الشباك وتطلع منه
وهذا يسبب مشاكل
احنا اتبعنا أسلوب أن الحرية موجودة اليوم
لأي مساهم يبغى يطلع من الشّركة العائليّة
عملنا إجراءات محددة في الميثاق، في تقييم سنوي يُعمل لأسهم الشّركة
في خصم، وهذا زي أي خصم يُعطي لأي شركة مملوكة من..
شركة خاصة غير مدرجة مملوكة من مساهمين خارج السوق المالية
خصم السيولة يسمونها ، وعملنا حقوق أولوية للمساهمين الموجودين
اليوم، تعاملنا حق الشفعة هذا بإجراءات محددة وواضحة
أي مساهم اليوم يبغى يبيع، فالحق الأول للمساهمين من الفرع اللي هو فيه
هم اللي لهم حق الأولوية في أنهم يشترونها هذه الأسهم
إذا ما في رغبة هناك نطلع للدائرة الأوسع من المساهمين، وأفراد العائلة
يصير لهم حق حسب نسبة ملكيّة كل واحد في الشّركة
وبعدين إذا باقي شيء نرجع للي عندهم رغبة يأخذوا حصة أكبر
من حصص ملكيتهم في الشّركة، وعملنا شيء، وهذا أعتقد أنه مهم
أن الشّركة، في النهاية إذا ما كان في رغبة في شراء أسهم
من عند أي من المساهمين من الشّركة العائليّة نفسها
لها الحق أنها تتملك أسهمها بما لا يتجاوز 10% حسب نظام الشّركات
بهذه الطريقة عملنا تنظيم لقضية التخارج أعتقد أنه مو مطمئن للمساهمين
ويأخذ في الاعتبار مصالح الشّركة المساهمة
فلو بلخصها أنا اليوم أنا عمر، أملك في «ماسك»
اللي بصير، أول شيء إذا قررت أني أتخارج
هذا الحق محفوظ لي ومتاح وميسّر
100%
فأجي أقول: أبغى أبيع حصتي اللي تساوي مليون ريال
أنتوا على طول تخصمون منها 20%
نعم
فأبيعها بـ800 ألف
لحظة، احنا نسوي تقييم
طبعًا، أنا أفترض أن تقييم السنة هذه مليون ريال
نعم
فراح يطبق خصم 20% هذا اللي هو لأني أنا أخذتها سيولة
أنت أخذت سيولة، والمساهمين أخذوا مخاطر بقاء الأسهم معهم
فهذا هو الخصم حق التقييم اللي المفروض أخذه أنا بشكل عادل
أول ناس لهم حق يشترون هذه الحصة حقتي الـ 800 ألف ريال
هم الفرع القريبين مني
بالضبط، إخوانك وخواتك الموجودين
إذا ما كان في أحد منهم يرغب، تروح للعائلة الأكبر اللي هم
كلٌ بحسب حصته
نعم
وبعدين إذا ما تغطت ففي اللي يبغى يأخذ حصة أكثر يتاح له
بالضبط
آخر خيار أنه إذا ما تغطت من العائلة، الشّركة تشتري هذه الأسهم
وتكون أسهم شركة، أو خزينة
أسهم خزينة نعم
بحيث أنها ما تطلع الحصص من العائلة
ولا يُمنع هذا الشخص اللي يبغى يغادر، أنه يغادر
وصارت الحالة هذه، لو تعطينا إيّاها
والحمد لله صارت نعم في أحد المساهمين كان
زي ما قلت لك: الرغبات تختلف من شخص لشخص
كان يبغى يوقف، ويسوي عمل خيري خارج الشّركة
والوقف تعرف كان غير متاح
وباع جزء من الأسهم بنفس الإجراءات اللي ذكرتها قبل شوي
وتمت العملية بكل سهولة، وسلاسة
والشيء اللي أثلج صدورنا كلنا يا أبو عبد الرحمن
وهذه أرجع وأكررها، وأفتخر فيها أن اللي اشتروا الأسهم هم البنات
وهذا يدلك كيف الشفافية، وسحرها، والوضوح والحوكمة
كيف خلى التزام البنات اتجاه الشّركة العائليّة
وما دامنا نتكلم في موضوع البنات والشفافية
ودّي نقفل هذا المحور بقصة أول جمعية عمومية
أختك «لولوة» الله يحفظها
الله يطول عمرها
لما دعيتها لهذه الجمعية
والله فعلًا هذا زي ما قلت لك: مشكلة ثقافية
يعانون منها كثير من العوائل السّعودية
قضية الثقة بين البنات والأولاد، وأنه أنا لا إذا جيت، وحضرت
وتابعت ودققت، أنا أشكك في إخواني
هذا شيء كان من أوائل الأشياء اللي لاحظناها
والحمد لله اهتمينا فيها
وقدرنا أننا فعلًا نكسر الحاجز هذا
وقصة أختي «لولوة» الله يحفظها، ويطول عمرها
كان في أول جمعية عمومية كنا بنوقع فيها الميثاق
فقلت لها: لازم تجين
قالت: لا ماني بجاية، شلون أجي، وأيش تبوني أسوي؟
قلت: الشّركة العائليّة، وشرحت لها
وذكرت لها جدول الأعمال كان مكتوب فيه
إبراء ذمة أعضاء مجلس الإدارة
قالت: أيش هو، أنا تبيني أجي، وأبري ذمة إخوانك؟ أنت صاحي؟
أنا واثقة فيكم، يلا روح بس ماني بجاية، أبد أبي أعطيكم وكالة
جيب لي ورقة بس بعطيكم وكالة، وأنتوا سووا اللي تبون، كذا تقول
قلت لها: إذا ما جيتي أنت الموضوع كله بيخرب، وبينهد
وأنا ماني بحاضر
قالت: ما علي منك رح كيفك أنا ماني بجاية، ولو تسوي اللي تسويه
قلت لها: بجي بمر عليك
وبأخذك بالسيارة أنت، وجيبي معك واحد من العيال
وتكلمنا مع بناتها، وعيالها، اقنعوها لازم تجي
ما اقتنعت إلا لما قلنا لها: جيبي واحد من العيال
والله يحفظه «نبيل» جاء معها، وأقنعها بأنها تجي
وأول ما جت كانت الجمعية الأولى هذه
عبارة عن خلني أقول لك: زلزال يمكن
النقاش، والشفافية اللي شافوها، وجبنا الرئيس التنفيذي
وعمل تقرير مجلس إدارة، وجبنا المراجع الخارجي، وموجود
وكان أي واحد يقدر يسأل
وأعضاء مجلس الإدارة، والمستقلين كانوا موجودين، يا أبو عبد الرحمن
فكانت أول مرة يتعرضون لشيء زي كذا، ويبدو لي، إن شاء الله
أنه هذا هو السبب الأساسي في الالتزام، والإبداع اللي نشوفه اليوم
الحمد لله، من البنات بالتحديد في دعمهم للشركة العائليّة
يمكن هذه الرحلة الطويلة، أبو خالد، من الحوكمة والمأسسة والشغل
الواحد يقول: هل تسوى وللا لا، هل تفرق وللا لا؟
خلاص عطني حصتي، وخلني أطلع أمشي
لكن اللي فهمته أنا أن كل هذا اللي صار، وهذا الجهد
أثمر أول شيء بتماسك العائلة كعائلة
في نمو الأصول، وثروة العائلة
وفي استمرار العمل الخيري اللي كان والدكم يحبّه، ويبغى يتوسع فيه
بل بالعكس أنتوا صرتوا تتوسعون فيه، وفي ترتيب المكتب العائلي
وراح نسولف الحين على موضوع العمل الخيري، والمكتب العائلي
بس أبغى أتجرأ وأسالك، وأقول: كم فرقت ثروتكم بعد الحوكمة؟
والله يا أبو عبد الرحمن، صدقًا هذه من الأسئلة اللي أنت تبي تخلي
إخواني وخواتي يطردوني من الشّركة العائلة
صدقًا ما هو فضول بقدر ما أني أبغى أوضح أن هذا الجهد
لأن بعض الناس يعتبرها مصاريف زايدة، وعبء إضافي
أبو عبد الرحمن، ما هي مثالية، لكن الرقم ما يفرق
ما أبغى أقول لك الرقم
لأن الرقم وصوله من هذا إلى هذا الرقم، ما هو فرق
تجد الفرق يا أبو عبد الرحمن في جودة هذا النمو اللي تحقق
الفرق في هذا المحرك اللي صنعناه، والحمد لله
واستدامته، وإلى أي مدى يأخذنا
أقول لك: من 2010 إلى اليوم تضاعفت الثروة ثلاثة مرات
ثلاث مرات!
ثلاث مرات، أبشرك
نتكلم على 300% ما شاء الله تبارك
الحمد لله، ولكن مو هذا المهم
المهم زي ما تفضلت، العلاقة الأسرية نمت
وصارت بيننا كإخوان، وكأبناء جيل المستقبل، أبشرك
علاقة جدًّا نظيفة ورائعة، وبعيدة عن
تعرف لما يقولون: وسخ الدنيا
والشيء الثاني: دعم الأسرة للشركة
وتفهّمهم لما يحدث فيها، والشفافية والوضوح
الشيء الثالث
قدرتنا على استقطاب الكفاءات هذا خلّى عندنا هذا المحرك
اللي له القدرة اليوم أن يصنع الفارق مو لنا كعائلة، للاقتصاد الوطني
دخلنا في مجالات اليوم، أبو عبد الرحمن، ما كنا نحلم ندخل فيها
وأحدثنا الحمد لله نجاحات في قطاعات
وأنت ما شاء الله، أحد المراجع في الرؤية
استطعنا ندخل في القطاعات أنا ما كنت أفهم فيها
ولا أحد من المساهمين كانوا يفهموا فيها
هذا الميزة والفرق
لو أنا قسّمت الثروة، أنا بشتغل بالشيء اللي أرتاح له
لأن أولًا: أنا صار حجمي صغير فما أخذ مخاطر عالية
لكن إذا اجتمعنا، وكنا مجموعة وعائلة، وعندنا رؤية وحدة
واستطعنا نبني فريق عمل محترف
قدرتنا على الدخول في مجالات، أكبر
قدرتنا على التعامل مع الدورات الاقتصادية والمخاطر
والتعامل معها بشكل أكبر
قدرتنا على تحقيق العوائد والاستثمارات والأرباح أكبر
ولو هذا الحلال تقسّم وتوزع
والأهم من هذا كله قبل
قدرتنا على عمل مشاريع المسؤولية الاجتماعية في الشّركة أكبر
ودعم المؤسسة الخيرية، مؤسسة «غروس» الخيرية
اللي أسسناها، الوالد والوالدة، الله يرحمهم، واحنا معهم، بشكل أكبر
فهذا كلّه يصب في أن الرقم، يا أبو عبد الرحمن، ما هو مهم
بقدر أهمية
لو أعطيتنا نسبة، تكفينا
أن في هذا الحراك كله أدّى إلى أن الثروة تتماسك
وتتضاعف وتتعظم، ولو هي مقسّمة
قطعًا ما راح تجيب أنت يا عبد العزيز، وللا يا «أبو خالد»
«هاني حلواني» يدير ثروتك، لكن لأنها بهذا الحجم
فأنت تقدر تجيب كفاءة بهذا المستوى
وتعطيه حوافز مقسّمة على عشرة أخوان
لكن أنت لحالك ما راح تتحملها
وما راح تدخل في القطاعات المتنوعة اللي دخلت فيها
صحيح، على فكرة احنا وحدة من الأشياء اللي
أنت حكيت عن التنوع، جبت الكلمة، وذكرتني في سالفة
احنا فشلنا في أننا ننوع جغرافيًّا استثماراتنا
احنا شركة استثمرت في السّعودية تاريخيًّا، وبقينا فيها، وحاولنا
كان في محاولات خجولة أن نخرج برة السّعودية، ولكنّا فشلنا فيها
لأن أولًا يمكن التنظيم ما كان عندنا، وهذا الآن ساعد
الكفاءات ما كانت موجودة، لأنك تحتاجها مختلفة
هذا اللي أقول لك: الخروج برة ثقافة العائلة صعب، وبتفشل فيه
إذا نظّمت، وكنت متّحد، وكان عندك الحجم تستطيع تدخل في قطاعات
فوجود اليوم الإدارة المحترفة بقيادة الأخ «هاني حلواني»
وبقية فريق العمل اللي نفتخر فيهم
«ماسك» اليوم صنعت أكبر برنامج سعودي للاستثمار
في الشّركات الناشئة في العالم
احنا نستثمر في كل دول العالم
وهذا أول مرة نطلع برة السّعودية بحجم كبير
فاستطعنا أننا نُطلق برنامج، بإذن الله، احنا فخورين فيه
ونتوقع، إن شاء الله
أنه بكون من أفضل البرامج الاستثمارية، والمستدامة
للاستثمار في قطاع الشّركات الناشئة والتقنية، والقطاعات الحديثة
يُضاف لشركة «جدوى» وبنك «البلاد» موضوع «فجر كابيتال»
موضوع «الأرجان للتطوير العقاري» موضوع، قبلهم كلهم
الشّركة الوطنية للاستزراع المائي اللي هي «نقوا»
وكذلك «مذاخر» و«وماسك اللوجستية» و«ميم لإدارة المرافق»
الملفت لما أتابع هذه الاستثمارات
أحس أنكم موازين لتوجّهات وملفات الرؤية
فالاستزراع السمكي اليوم من أحد أهم الملفات
ومبروك، ما شاء الله، الباي إف استحوذ على حصة
نعم «سالك» قبل أسبوع، الحمدلله، استحوذ على حصة
في «نقوا»
فخورين في هذا الإنجاز
تستاهلون، الله يبارك لكم
«ماسك» في موضوع الخدمات اللوجستية
هذه انطلقت بعدما أُطلقت الرؤية
واتضح أن أحد ركائزنا هي محور ربط القارات، والتركيز على القطاع هذا
نتكلم على «ذاخر» مشروع عملاق
من أكبر مشاريع القطاع الخاص في مكة المكرمة
بالطريقة اللي تخفّف الضغط على المنطقة المركزية
أنتم قريبين بعيدين
ضمن حدود الحرم بس ما أنتوا في جنب الحرم
وسط المنطقة المركزية
وبدأ البيع في المشروع، واللي هو يخدم ضيوف الرحمن، وبرنامج خدمتهم
فأبغى أسألك عن الفرص اللي أنتوا شايفينها
وأهم القطاعات اللي اختلف وضعها بعد إطلاق الرؤية
وصرتوا مركزين عليها أو مهتمين فيها
النمو في الثروة ما جاء من فراغ، أبو عبد الرحمن
أنت لما تكون منظّم عملك
وتكون مسوي إجراءات وسياسات داخلية في العمل العائلي
تُبدع في استغلال وقتك في التركيز على النظرة طويلة الأمد
وهذه أحد أهم فوائد التنظيم
صرنا نشوف من فوق وين التوجهات، نعطي رأينا، وقراراتنا
ونناقش، وندخل على مستوى مجلس الإدارة، والشّركات التابعة
ووجود الأعضاء المستقلين
يُضيف إلى جودة النقاش اللي تحصل على مستوى مجلس الإدارة
وهذا اللي أنتج الحمد لله، النجاحات اللي ذكرتها، يا أبو عبدالرحمن
ما جت بسهولة وصدفة، جت بالتركيز على الفرص اللي خلقتها رؤية
المملكة العربية السّعودية 2030
واللي أشوف أنها عملية إعادة هيكلة ضخمة للاقتصاد السّعودي
نَتج عنها، وبينتج عنها فرص لن تتكرر
أشوف أنه حرام أن الشّركات العائليّة، والقطاع الخاص بشكل عام
ما يستفيد من تجربة إعادة الهيكلة اللي تصنعها الرؤية اليوم
وهي شيء ما يحدث إلا كل 200-300 سنة في أي اقتصاد
ولا أشوف أن في اقتصاد في أي دولة في العالم
حدث فيه ما يحدث عندنا
وحجم وعدد الفرص اللي نشوفها كل يوم، ولا نستفيد منها
وعلى فكرة كثير من الأجانب يشوفونها اليوم
فاليوم الفرصة موجودة، ولن تكون بشكل دائم
أتوقع بعد فترة بكون في التقاط لهذه الفرص من جهات خارجية
لفت نظري أن كل استثماراتكم، أو جُلها، يمكن في استثناء واحد
كُلها ما أنتوا لحالكم دائمًا في شريك، فبنك «البلاد» أنتوا ما حوّلتوا
مصرفيتكم لحالكم، دخلتوا معكم ناس
صحيح
«جدوى» و«ذاخر» أسستوهم بالشركاء
«نقوا» داخلين أنتم و«الراجحي» مع «البلّاع»
مين الظاهر دخلت معك شركة ماليزية
ماليزية، صحيح
في إدارة المرافق
فما تشتغلون لحالكم، ليش؟
هذه أحد القيم، يا أبو عبد الرحمن، اللي ورثناها من الوالد
واللي اليوم الإدارة التنفيذية تشبّعت، وآمنت، والتزمت فيها
فعلًا وجود شركاء متعددين يعطيك قوة، وحجم في القطاع
زي ما تكلمنا اليوم عن الحجم والقوة على مستوى الشّركة العائليّة
قد ما تقدر تخلق حجم، وتنوع على مستوى القطاع، أو الشّركة التابعة
هذا يعطيك قدرة على أنك تسوي مشروع، وتتحمل مخاطر أكبر
نفس الكلام اللي كررناهم في الشّركة العائليّة، ووحدتها
نُكرّره في أسلوب عملنا في الشّركات التابعة، واستقطاب خبرات
اليوم أغلب قطاعات الرؤية، زي ما تفضلت
جديدة على كثير من العاملين في السّعودية اليوم
فالطريقة الوحيدة أنك تشارك اللي على الأقل عنده تجربة وخبرة
والفريق التنفيذي في شركة «ماسك» اليوم مُؤمن بهذه الرؤية
ويطبقها بشكل كبير، اليوم في كل استثماراتنا نسعى لاستقطاب شركاء
المهم في النقطة هذه، أنك تستقطب الشريك الصحيح
واللي يؤمن معك بنفس الرؤية، والثقافة والقيم، هذه مهمة جدًّا
بلا شك، أنا كنت في مشروع البحر الأحمر قبل أيام قليلة
وسولفوا لي عن جمعية خيرية جديدة، وقالوا: من شركائنا «السبيعي»
أنا عارف القصة وأنت شرحت لي إيّاها، بس سويت نفسي ما أعرف هناك
قلت لهم: ليش اخترتوا «السبيعي»؟ في جمعيات خيرية في البلد مهولة
قالوا: هم من القلائل اللي لقيناهم عندهم نموذج الاستثمار
في شركات الريادة الاجتماعية أو الأثر الاجتماعي
فهذا مدخل جيد نوضح كيف أثر تنظيم الشّركة العائليّة خدمكم
بأنكم تعظّمون، وتواصلون العمل الخيري
اللي والدكم، الله يرحمه، كان مُحب له
بل كتب في وصيته «أتمنى أن تستمرون عليه»
وتحبّبون أحفادي في العمل الخيري، مو كان هذا اللي ذكره؟
صحيح، الله يغفر له ويرحمه
فعطنا، أيش صار في موضوع العمل الخيري أو الغير ربحي؟
احنا انطلاقًا من صك الوالد الوصية والوقف اللي ذكرت
ونظرًا لتغيّر الظروف، والتطور الكبير في التشريعات والأنظمة
اللي المملكة العربية السّعودية قامت بها
وجدنا من المهم أن العمل الخيري يتنظّم
واستخدمنا نفس التقنيات والأفكار اللي نظمنا فيها الشّركة العائليّة
في تنظيم العمل الخيري، وأسّسنا مؤسسة خيرية اسمها «غروس»
مؤسّسة «محمد إبراهيم السبيعي وأولاده الخيرية، غروس»
وحبينا أنها تكون مؤسسة مختلفة
شفنا وين الفراغ الموجود في العمل الخيري
وين القطاعات اللي ما هي مغطاة
وحاولنا نغطيها في رؤيتنا لتأسيس هذه المؤسسة
وأحد أهم الثغيرات اللي وجدناها هو الاستثمار الاجتماعي
مفهوم الاستثمار الاجتماعي اليوم، هو متطور في العالم
وحبينا نستفيد منه ونجيبه، ونطبقه في السّعودية
لأنه يخلق عمل خيري وذو أثر ومستدام
هذه معادلة تعظّم، وتديم الأثر في أي عمل تقوم فيه
والحمد لله، وحدة من أولى الأفكار اللي طلعت فيها المؤسسة
هي تأسيس جمعية زراعية تعاونية في البحر الأحمر
تكون مسؤولة عن تطوير مزارع الأفراد
ومساعدتهم في أهم قضية من القضايا
أبو عبد الرحمن تعرف، ما شاء الله
عندنا جودة منتجات رائعة في السّعودية
التحدي في التسويق
صحيح
التحدي في التسويق والتدريب
على استخدام التقنيات الحديثة في الزراعة
هذه الاثنين راح تكون الجمعية هذه، بإذن الله، رائدة في تغطيتها
وبدعم من برامج الرؤية، وأحد أهم برامجها
وشركات صندوق الاستثمارات العامة، شركة «البحر الأحمر»
استطاعت الجمعية هذه توقيع اتفاقية مع «البحر الأحمر»
اتفاقية «أوف تيك» راح تشتري من المزارع اللي هناك، بإذن الله
أول ما تنطلق الفنادق هناك، وتفتح أبوابها
وراح يكون المحتوى المحلي موجود في مشترياتها
وبدأنا اليوم نتعامل مع مزارع العوائل اللي يشتغلون فيها أهل المنطقة هناك
حصلتوا أكثر من ألف مزرعة
ما تتخيل كيف مزارع المنقا والتمور والفواكه والخضروات
شيء رائع أبو عبد الرحمن
ولكن يحتاج إلى شوية أفكار، راح نأخذ المنتجات ونساعدهم
واتفقنا على معادلة
وهذه اللي أقول لك: الاستدامة المالية من وين جت؟
اتفقنا مع المزارع على معادلة أن أي ربح إضافي يتحقق لك
من تطبيق أفكار التسويق، والتدريب والتقنيات الجديدة اللي تستخدمها
70 إلى 80% راح يكون لك يا المزارع
والجمعية هذه راح تأخذ بس 20 إلى 30% لتغطية مصروفاتها
وعملنا معهم طريقة
بأن كلما طبقت تقنيات أكثر، كلما زادت هذه النسبة عندك أكثر
كلما أعطيتنا المنتج بجودة أفضل بتزيد مساهمتك
فالجمعية هذه دورها حاجتين
رقم واحد: أنها تأهل المزارعين
لاستخدام التقنيات الزراعية الحديثة اللي ترفع كفاءتهم
ورقم اثنين: أنها تشتري، وتسوّق لمنتجاتهم
وحق المزارع محفوظ، تكلفته هذه مضمونة له
وفوق كذا، أي ربح يحقّقه الأغلب له 80%
20% لهذه الجمعية، عكس اللي حاصل اليوم
اليوم، الوسيط اللي هم عادةً من عمالة أو جاليات معينة
يجي يشتري المحصول بتراب الفلوس من المزارع
ويروح يبيعه في السوق ماخذ الهامش الأكبر
هذا الوسيط اللي في النص
أنتوا اليوم قلبتوها، صار الهامش الأكبر يروح للمزارع اللي تعب
وأخذ المخاطرة، وصنع القيمة، وأنتوا تأخذون الجزء الأقل كجمعية
لضمان استدامة عملكم
صحيح، اليوم نشوف سلسلة الإمداد في القطاع الزراعي
المزارع أكثر واحد يأخذ مخاطر، ويبذل جهد، ويتعب
وأقل واحد يأخذ ربح
صحيح
تلقاهم في النهاية يبسط قدام مزرعته، وللا يسوي له محل، ولا كذا
أو يجي اللي هم الوسطاء زي ما تفضلت، الشريطية حقينا
ويشترون المحصول حقه، وفي خلال يوم أو يومين يحققون اللي حققه
في سنة
أضعاف اللي حقّقه المزارع في الموسم كامل
سواءً ثلاثة شهور أو شهرين، وهو يزرع ويتعب، تلقى الوسيط يحصّل
دور الجمعية التعاونية هو أنها تحل محل الوسيط هذا
وتكون ممكّن للمزارع في إيصال منتجاته الزراعية بشكل صحيح
وهذا النموذج اللي كانت تفتقده المملكة العربية السّعودية من زمان
أنا أذكر، في مبادرات كثيرة صارت من الدولة
صحيح
على حل هذه الإشكالية، ولكنها ما انحلت
لأنها كانت تخلق، الأفكار كلها كانت مبنية على أنك تخلق شركة
والشركة بطبيعتها ربحية، ولازم تعظّم ربحها
صحيح
هذه لأول مرة
يكون الوسيط هو عبارة عن جمعية تعاونية، وليست شركة ربحية
التجربة الثانية رائعة جدًّا، وهذه أنا حبيت فيها نفس المبدأ
أن في تحدي أو مشكلة تدخلون بنموذج مالي مستدام، وتحلونه
موضوع الهدر الغذائي، السّعودية من الأعلى فيه
وهذا من فضل الله، وكثر نعمته صار الهدر هائل جدًّا، وهو شيء مؤلم
والكل يبغى يتعامل معه، بس ما في إلى الآن حل عملي
أنتوا دخلتوا باستثمار في «دوم لتدوير الخبز»
نعم
قصة رهيبة، ونهايتها ملفتة
أو مو نهايتها، اللي وصلتوا له اليوم، ملفتة
لأن القصة لسّه لها تكملة، فأيش قصة «دوم»؟
مؤسسة «غروس الخيرية» وجدت أحد رواد العمل الخيري
كان عنده شغف وحب في العمل الخيري، وكان يشتغل في أحد الجمعيات
وجد أن الناس دائمًا تلقى الخبز معلق على
الخبز بالتحديد، ماني عارف ليش
في حاجز نفسي أنك ترمي الخبز في النفايات
فدائمًا تلقى الخبز معلق، ففكر وقال: كيف أحل المشكلة هذه
وأخدم العاملين أو الناس في كيف يحافظون على هذه النعمة
فراح جاب سلّات خبز بجهد شخصي في البداية
وصار يوزعها بسعر رمزي على البيوت
وهذه السّلات مصنوعة بشكل معين بحيث أنها تجفف الخبز
وما تسبب تلفه، ويمر يأخذها منها في نهاية كل أسبوع، وللا شيء
يكون خبز مجفف، ويستفيد منها في الأعلاف والأسمدة
يبيعها؟
هو في البدايات لا ما كان يبيعها، كان يروح يعطيها، مجرد عمل خيري
ولما بدأ يسوي الشيء هذا اشتغل هو وأولاده وبناته في هذا الموضوع
وجد أن في طريقة يخلي العمل مستدام
في أنه أولًا: يبيع المنتج هذا اللي هو الخبز الجاف
وثانيًا: وجد شيء غريب أن الناس عندها استعداد تدفع مقابل السلّة
مع أن من أول كان يوزعها مجانًا، قال: أنه لا
أدفع لك عشان تريح ضميري
فهنا هو جاء بحث عن مستثمرين
لأن تعرف الموضوع يحتاج الآن إلى رأس مال، ويحتاج إلى
فاكتشفت «غروس» الموضوع هذا، ودخلت معه في شراكة
عمل استثمار اجتماعي، وهو عمل خيري
ولكنه يعتمد على قواعد الاستثمار
فسوّت شركة هو وعائلته، يملكون الحصة فيه
ودخلت «غروس» وبعض أفراد العائلة من عندنا
دخلوا مساهمين في الشّركة هذه
وبدأت تمارس العمل بشكل منظم ومحوكم أكثر
وما تتخيل كيف التوسع اليوم والطلب
سوينا موقع على الانترنت والتواصل الاجتماعي، والآن في طور التطبيق
بنسوي تطبيق لهذا الموضوع، بحيث أنك تطلب بشكل إلكتروني، السلّة
ويمكن نتعاقد مع شركات التوصيل الموجود
نموذج عمل متطور جدًّا ومستدام
لإدارة الهدر الغذائي
لإدارة هدر الخبز الآن، ويمكن، إن شاء الله
نتوسع بعدين إلى منتجات أخرى غير الخبز
واليوم الشّركة عندها تدفقات نقدية موجبة، لأنها ربحانة الشركة
ما شاء الله، الشركة اليوم عندها تدفقات نقدية، ونمو مهول
واحنا ما بدأنا إلا بس في الرياض
ومتوقعين نطلع، إن شاء الله، لمدن ودول أخرى، أبشّرك
جاءنا طلب من بعض الدول في المنطقة أن نعيد التجربة هناك
وهذا دائمًا يؤكد أن الحل إذا جاء بأُسس الأعمال أو التجارية
وله أثر اجتماعي هذه الوصفة السحرية لحل عميق، ومستدام
ما راح يوقف بكرة، لأن الداعمين أو الممولين بوقفون
حتى المسجد خليتوه يربح، أيش قصته؟
لا تشوه سمعتنا، يا أبو عبدالرحمن، لا ما في مسجد ربحان
في مسجد مستدام مغطي مصاريفه، صح وللا لا؟
الحمد لله هذه وحدة من الأفكار اللي بدأت
الفكرة من معالي الدكتور «توفيق الربيع»
الله يمسيه بالخير ويطول عمره ويحفظه
كان في نقاش سابق عن موضوع مسجد الأحياء، ودورها في المجتمع
وكيف ممكن نخلق نموذج يكون صديق للبيئة
ونموذج يكون فيه ربط لأهل الحي في المسجد
بخدمات، وخدمة المعوقين سواءً الإعاقة البصرية أو السمعية أو الحركية
وكيف فعلًا نخلق نموذج عمل يكون قادر على أن يصرف المسجد
بنفسه على نفسه
اليوم أبو عبد الرحمن تشوف وضع المساجد
وهذا الشيء مؤسف في السّعودية
وتقارنه مثلًا بالموجود في دول أخرى إسلامية
تجد المساجد عندنا مبنية بشكل ما يأخذ في الاعتبار معايير الاستدامة
ولا يأخذ حتى الكفاءة التشغيلية ولا الهدر
وتلقى المسجد هدر في المساحة والمال والطاقة والمياه، وقِس عليها
فكان الفكرة أننا نخلق نموذج يُعالج هذه المشاكل كلها
وبدأنا أول نموذج «مسجد معمور» في الرياض، واستطعنا فعلًا
في قرطبة نعم، والمسجد حظى بدعم جميع الجهات الحكومية مشكورة
من وزارة الشؤون الإسلامية إلى وزارة الشؤون البلدية والقروية
وحصل على، لأنه كان نموذج جديد
دخلنا بعض الفراغات في المسجد بطريقة تخدم أهل الحي بشكل ممتاز
أخذنا نماذج في توفير الطاقة، والمياه، وعملنا حدائق، وإضاءة طبيعية
بالنسبة للأرصفة والحركه تأخذ في الاعتبار الإعاقة البصرية والحركية
الإعاقة السمعية في وقت الأذان المنارة تتحول إلى لون مختلف
بحيث أنه يشوفها اللي عنده إعاقه سمعية، ويعرف أن هذا أذان بدأ الآن
ووقت الصلاة نفس الشيء
في الأوقات العادية يكون في النور الأبيض العادي مثلًا
كم في المئة معتمد على الطاقة الشمسية؟
أعتقد وصلوا الآن إلى 25% من استهلاك الكهرباء
الجاية من الطاقة المتجددة
وكم في المئة من المياه معاد تدويرها أو استخدامها؟
استخدام الحدائق وصلنا إلى 100% الحدائق من المياه المدورة
وأنتوا سويتوا حركة في موضوع فراغات المسجد عادةً
أو مساجدنا للأسف أن في مبنى ضخم، الصف الأول هو اللي مليان
لا مو بالصف الأول، عادةً في مساجدنا تلقى مصمم المسجد بشكل كبير
عشان مثلًا صلاة الجمعة، وللا الأعياد، وللا كذا
فتلقى في الفروض العادية دائمًا يرجعون وراء
فأنت تركت أجمل مكان اللي هو مكان المحراب، والمكان اللي فيه..
خلق المسجد أو مُيّز المسجد فيه
ورحت ترجع وراء، ومكان مظلم ما يستخدم إلا مرة في الأسبوع
ساعة في الأسبوع أو ساعتين
فرحنا في التصميم احنا سوينا أن خلينا المكان
اللي هو الرئيسي في المسجد
اللي هو مكان المحراب والمنبر، هو المكان اللي يُصلّي فيه يوميًا
وحوّلنا الفراغات الأخرى إلى فراغات متعددة الاستخدامات
المسجد صار فيه روضة أطفال، وصيدلية، وبقالة
وصار في جهاز صرف آلي أو صرّاف، وهذه كلها
وقاعة متعددة الاستخدامات
أظن استخدمت في المناسبات الاجتماعية للحي
نعم، لمناسبات الزواج واللقاء الأسبوعي لأهل الحي وكذا
ومعايدات وكذا، ولكن كلها هذه تستغلها في
الفراغ زي هذا تستغله، وروضة الأطفال تستغلها في الصلوات
في أوقات الذروة
فعكسنا المعادلة، فأنت اليوم تصلي يوميًا في أحسن مكان
وفي الأيام اللي تحتاج فيه إلى عدد مصلين أكبر
تفتح الفراغات هذه على الفراغ الرئيسي، وتستفيد منها
وهذه الصيدلية والروضة والبقالة والصراف كلهم مستأجرين
من الشّركة المالكة للمسجد
نعم، شركة وقفية، عشان بس ما تقول: ربحية، هي شركة وقفية
وهذه الإيرادات غطّت مصاريف المسجد؟
نعم، أبشرك
وفي فائض؟
تحت إشراف وزارة الشؤون الإسلامية، والجهات الأخرى
واللي لها علاقة، كلهم
استطعنا الحصول على دعم كبير
فأنتوا حليتوا مشاكل المسجد، ووفرتوا خدمات لأهل الحي
صحيح
وحسّنتوا تجربة المصلي
جدًّا، اليوم الروضة عليها قائمة انتظار
واللي يشغلها شركة سعودية، وشباب سعوديين
البقالة، امرأة من أهل الحي هي اللي ماسكة البقالة، وتشغلها
وأبشرك حقّقت أرباح، واليوم تفكر تفتح بقالة ثانية برة
ما شاء الله
الصيدلية كذلك، سبحان الله
الصيدلية لأنها موجودة في المسجد صار في ارتباط عاطفي
تعرف المريض أحيانًا يسعى لأنه يأخذ الجانب النفسي في الموضوع
فصار يشتري الأدوية من الصيدلية هذه ما يروح يشتريها من مكان آخر
زائد أنها أقرب له بطبيعة الحال، رايح أصلي، وأنا طالع أشتري
ونفس الشيء الصراف
وجدنا أن الأطفال صاروا يجون للمكان هذا
لأن الشباب يجون للمكان هذا، لأنه صار مرح وجميل
وهو طالع يأخذ له شيء من البقالة
وللا وهو داخل يأخذ له قهوة وللا شيء
فصار في ارتباط أهل الحي بالمسجد والفعاليات اللي فيه
شيء ثاني البرامج الموجودة في المسجد
استطعنا تطوير برنامج مثلًا مع جمعية الهلال الأحمر
برامج الرعاية الأولية، والإسعافات الأولية
برامج مع جهات كثير تعليمية وتثقيفية
كان فعلًا تجربة وفكرة رائدة لربط أهل الحي بالمسجد
وإعادة فكرة المسجد زي ما كان في صدر الإسلام
مركز لاجتماع الناس وتلاقيهم، والتعلم، وعمل أشياء مفيدة للناس
ويمكن هذه تؤكد أن مفهوم الاستدامة دائمًا تأتي مصلحته للجميع
100%
بس الملف هنا أن رغم نجاح التجربة من كل النواحي ما تكرّرت
سويتوا مسجد واحد ووقفتوا
لا، أبشرك
كيف؟
هو كان في تحدي زي ما قلت لك، بفهم التشريعات والتنظيمات
والحمد لله، هو أنت تخلق نموذج أول
بعدين تحاول تغير أو تأخذ في الاعتبار التشريعات الموجودة
لأن كان في تخوفات من النموذج هذا، وكنا ما احنا واثقين في نجاحها
فقلنا: خلونا نسوي النموذج، ونتأكد. فدائمًا النموذج الأول يأخذ وقت
بس أبشّرك الآن الشّركة الوقفية شركة «المساجد المتكاملة»
أبشّرك اليوم عندها طلب كبير في إعادة التجربة هذه
في مساجد أخرى، وفي متبرعين كثير صاروا يتواصلون مع الشّركة
لتكرار هذا النموذج في أحيان كثيرة، سواءً في الرياض أو خارجها
وأبشرك بُشرى أخرى أن جتنا طلبات من دول أخرى في المنطقة
جتنا من مصر والإمارات والأردن طلبات لإعادة النموذج هذا، وخلقه هناك
الله يقويكم، أنا بختم بتجربة رهيبة لأنها تؤكد مفهوم «غروس»
كمؤسسة تُركز على ريادة الأعمال الاجتماعية، والأثر المستدام
أبغاك تحكي لي قصتكم مع «وتين» مع أنه ما هو بمشروعكم
ولكن الاحتكاك معكم أدّى إلى تحول جوهري في المشروع
أيش صار؟
«وتين» هو مشروع رائد كان أُسس من قبل مجموعة شباب سعوديين
يمكن تعرف أغلبهم، أبو عبد الرحمن
والنعم فيهم
والنعم فيك وفيهم
تجربة رائعة في موضوع التبرع بالدم، وإدارتها
وبدأت كعمل خيري، ولقت كثير من الدعم والرعايات
لأنه فعلًا كانت..
وتحولت مع الوقت إلى نموذج لإدارة بنوك الدم في السّعودية
كثير من المستشفيات صارت تسوي مصدر خارجي «لروتين»
أن تعالي ديروا لنا العمل في بنوك الدم، ونقله من مستشفى إلى أخرى
ومن مدينة لأخرى بحسب الاحتياج، وتخصصوا في هذا المجال
بس ما زال نموذج كان يعتمد على التبرعات
كان كل ثلاث سنوات يوقعون عقد مع شركة ترعى التطبيق هذا
ويأخذون منها مبلغ مقابل الرعاية
فالله يذكرهم بالخير جونا هنا في «ماسك»
وقالوا: نبغاها من ضمن مسؤوليتها الاجتماعية أنها ترعى التطبيق
وأول شيء صدمناهم فيه
قلنا لهم: ما عندنا بس نبغى تعطونا نموذج استدامة
للفلوس اللي بنعطيكم إيّاها
أنتم ما تحتاجون اليوم تصرفون على شيء، ما شاء الله تبارك الله
أموركم بدأت تتحسن وكذا، بس نبغى الفلوس هذه اللي بنعطيكم إيّاها
تعطونا وشلون تبي تستخدمونها
علشان توصلون للتوازن والاستدامة المالية
فانصدموا من الطلب هذا، زعلوا علينا شوي
قالوا: كيف تتشرطون علينا، قلنا: هذا الشرط تبون، وللا؟
فالله يذكرهم بالخير، تقبلوا الفكرة والتحدي، فعلًا كان تحدي
وهذه أبو عبد الرحمن، قد كثير من الناس ينظرون لهذا الموضوع
أنه نظرة مادية بحتة، وهو والله لا، وما احنا بشينين
هو فعلًا محاولة، أنت قلتها الكلمة
استخدام تقنيات وأدوات العمل الاستثماري في العمل الخيري، والعائلي
صحيح، راح نجيها سالفة المطبخ
لا، إلا المطبخ. فالله يجزاهم خير، قبل فترة جونا
وطلبوا اجتماع الزملاء في «وتين»
وبدأوا الاجتماع، قالوا: جزاكم الله خير
أنتم بطلبكم هذا اللي زعلنا أول شيء، فتّح لنا آفاقنا ومداركنا
لأشياء وقرارات سويناها، وكانت سبب اليوم في أن، الحمد لله
«وتين» يصير ما هو بس مستدام ماليًا، صار مربح
ما شاء الله
أبشرك، صار مُربح، ومطلوب من دول أخرى
وأعتقد أنهم راحوا للكويت الآن، والبحرين ولدول كثيرة
هذا دليل على أن فعلًا تطبيق مبادئ الاستثمار الاجتماعي
اللي مطّبق في دول كثير سابقتنا في العمل الخيري
يجب أن نتبناهم بشكل كبير، وبشكل أسرع
عشان ما نظلم التجربة، لأن ذكرتها ودّي أختم فيها العمل الخيري
ثم ننتقل لآخر جزء في حلقتنا موضوع تطبيق «مالي»
أنتوا مواكبين الرؤية وأولوياتها بما يخدم ثقافتكم
ونشاطكم الرئيسي ككيان استثماري
أنتوا اشتغلتوا على موضوع زيادة الوعي المالي
وزيادة ثقافة الادخار والاستثمار عند الأطفال
لو تحدثنا عن تطبيق «مالي» والأثر اللي حققه
بحكم أن الوالد رجل مالي، الله يغفر له ويرحمه
كان دائمًا يدربنا على كيف استخدام المال، والتصرف فيه، والأولويات
طلعنا بالعائلة أسّست مؤسسة وقفية اسمها «ميم عين»
وهذه بعيدة عن «ماسك» كانت بجهد من أفراد العائلة أنفسهم
وكان هدف «ميم عين» هو معالجة بعض الإشكاليات التعليمية عند الأطفال
ومساعدة برامج التعليم العام في الوصول لأهداف الرؤية
فيما يتعلق بزيادة الوعي، وحماية الأطفال، ورفع مستوى التعليم
فكانت متخصصة في هذا المجال
أول برنامج أطلقناه هو «مالي» وهو متخصص بزيادة الوعي المالي
والثقافة المالية والاقتصاد السلوكي لدى الأطفال
والبرنامج مكون من لعبة الكترونية، ولعبة ورقية وقصص
مجموعة مع بعض، تطبّق في بيئة معينة للأطفال
سواءً في المدرسة أو في أحد المراكز أو المجتمعات
وتساهم في رفع الوعي المالي عند الطفل
وتعريفه بمصطلحات الاستثمار والادخار، وتحديد الأولويات
وعشان نخلق نموذج عمل مستدام، وجدنا أن فيه في برامج الرؤية
أهداف معينة موجود اليوم على القطاع البنكي
وتحت مظلة البنك المركزي
وحاولنا أننا نخلق أو نبني أو نضمّن هذه الأهداف
في البرنامج التثقيفي للأطفال، ونجحنا أبشرك، الحمد لله
في أننا ما هو نستقطب فقط البنك المركزي والبنوك السّعودية
في دعم هذا البرنامج
بل حتى بعض برامج الأمم المتحدة «الآي تي يو»
وجهات أخرى تُعنى بالتعليم في العالم
لما شافوا النموذج وقيّموه، وجدوا أن النموذج فريد في نوعه في العالم
في أنك كيف تستخدم التلعيب أول اللعبة بدون ما يحس الطفل
في أنه يجمع مصطلحات، ويرفع مستوى ثقافته المالية
واستفاد منها 50 ألف حتى الآن، وللا لا؟
صحيح
ما شاء الله، تبارك الله
وبدعم البنك المركزي السّعودي، بإذن الله
متوقع أننا نصل إلى برنامج أوسع وأشمل
على مستوى المملكة العربية السّعودية
وبإذن الله، راح ينطلق قريبًا برنامج واسع في هذا المجال
وقابلت أنا «بندر العامر» اللي ماسك الموضوع
وقال لي قديش أنه حاطين عليه أهداف أنه يتحول للاستدامة المالية
ما بعد وصل لها، لكنكم فوق رأسه إلى أن يستديم ماليًا
صحيح، لا أبشرك، إن شاء الله، في كثير من البنوك السّعودية اليوم
ترغب في أنها مثلًا من ضمن اللعبة تحط إعلاناتها وحساباتها المعينة
بعض الأشياء، ففي أفكار في موضوع الاستدامة المالية، إن شاء الله
ممتاز، أنا ودي أختم بآخر جزء
واللي ما راح نطول فيه احترامًا لخصوصية العائليّة
ولكن هو ركن أساسي في التنظيم
بعض الأشخاص يعتقد أن إذا نظم الشّركة العائليّة، وحط هذه الضوابط
أنه يخسر امتيازات أو يفقد بعض المكتسبات
والعائلة هي الأساس، في الركن الأساسي في كل القصة هذه كلها
فكثير من العوائل عندها أملاك مشتركة أو منازل أو مزارع أو مرافق
تجمع هذه العائلة، ومناسبات اجتماعية لهذه العائلة
فأنتوا، هذا الترتيب والتنظيم والحوكمة أثره إيجابي يمتد إلى حتى
شؤون أسرية وعائليه بأنكم حافظتوا على كثير من الأشياء
اللي كانت ممكن تفقد أو تضيع
لو فككت التركة أو الورث، وانتهت التنظيمات
ومن ضمنها المطبخ المركزي اللي صار كيان ربحي الحين
أنتوا كل شيء تحولونه لربح؟ يدكم السحرية، ما شاء الله
الله يبارك لكم
الله يجزاك خير
حدثنا عن مكتب العائلة، كيف قدرتوا أنتوا تضيفونه ضمن هذه القصة؟
أحد أهم الأركان الأساسية اللي الميثاق غطّاها، يمكن ما تطرقنا لها
هو مكتب العائلة
زي ما قلنا: الميثاق يتكلم عن الملكيّة والإدارة والشّركة العائليّة
ولكنه يتكلم عن العائلة، في بندين في الميثاق لهم علاقة بالعائلة
وأقل علاقة بالعمل أو الشّركة العائليّة
اللي هم مجلس العائلة، ومكتب العائلة
مجلس العائلة هو المظلة اللي تجمع العائلة بالكامل
سواءً كانوا مساهمين في الشّركة أو لا
وهذه تنظيم ولجنة وعمل وبرامج متخصصة بس لدعم العائلة
وتجمع العائلة، والتقائها، وبعض المبادرات الاجتماعية والخيرية
فيما يتعلق بالعائلة
مكتب العائلة
هو عبارة عن مكتب يقدم خدماته للمساهمين من أفراد العائلة
وبالذات المساهمين اللي ما هم داخلين في العمل التجاري
ما هم في أعضاء مجلس إدارة، ما هم في..
وُجد أن دائمًا في خدمات معينة يستفيد منها جزء من المساهمين
اللي يشتغلون في الشّركة، واللي ما يشتغل تلقاهم محرومين منها
فمن باب تحقيق العدالة، وخلق قيمة مضافة
ودعم لأفراد العائلة سواءً كانوا ممارسين للعمل أو لا
وُجد مجموعة من الخدمات، وخلقنا هذا المكتب أو أسّسناه
وتشرف عليه لجنة من المساهمين لتقديم خدماته للمساهمين
فيما يتعلق في أمورهم الشخصية
سواءً كانت تأمين طبي أو أعمال سكرتارية
أعمال حجوزات سفر، والمراجعات الحكومية أو التعقيب
وأعمال مثلًا البرامج الصيفية، والعمالة المنزلية
واحنا كان عندنا أشياء مشتركة باقية
ما زالت مشتركة باسم المساهمين مع بعض
في استراحة أو بيت مثلًا موجود في مطبخ
هذا يخص كل المجموعة، كل المساهمين، ما يخص فرد
وما أخفيك كثير من المشاكل تجي من الأشياء المشتركة
إذا الأشياء المشتركة ما نظمت، أولًا يجب أن يكون أقل ما يمكن
ولكن هي لا بد منها، وجودها يزيد الترابط
وإذا وجدت لازم تتنظم بشكل صحيح
فالهدف كان من مكتب العائلة فعلًا أن يقدم خدماته في الملكيات المشتركة
وفي تقديم الخدمات للأفراد من أفراد العائلة المساهمين
فيما يتعلق بأشيائهم الشخصية، في أشياء ما يقدمها، وهذه نقطة مهمة
أموره مثلًا الشّركات أو العمل التجاري الخاص في كل واحد
هذا شأن خاص، ففي خطوط حمراء، وخدمات محددة يقدمها المكتب
ولا يتوسع في أكثر من هذا، وعلى فكرة ميزانية المكتب هذا
تدفع من المساهمين ما لها علاقة الشركة
تخصم من أرباح المساهمين
المساهم بعدما يجيه الربح احنا متفقين، وهذا متفق في ميثاق العائلة
جزء من الأرباح بسيط يروح لتغطية مصاريف مكتب العائلة
وكان وقتها يجيك أنت اتصالات عن البقدونس
لا يا أبو عبد الرحمن، ما اتفقنا على كذا، ربطة البقدونس هذه
ما احنا متوسعين، أبي بس قصة المطبخ، وبقفل الفصل هذا
شوف أبو عبدالرحمن أحيانًا
لأنه مثال حلو على كيف تنظم، وتطبّق نفس الثقافة
في ثقافة تطبقونها في شركتكم التجارية، وعملكم الخيري
وتطبقونها في شؤونكم الأسرية، فبس نبي قصة البقدونس والمطبخ
وبعدها أوعدك أقفل الموضوع
في أشياء كثير، الله يغفر له، الوالد كان له مثل
يقول: «مليون في دربه ولا ريال في غير دربه»
في كثير أشياء حتى لو كانت بسيطة وتافهة
بس تفتح لك إشكال وثقافة غلط
فنرجع لقصة ربطة البقدونس
أنا كان لي صديق عزيز، وكنت..
أو كان عزيز، يمكن الحين بعد القصة هذه ما عاد صار يكلمني ويبغاني
كنت جالس أنا وإيّاه ونتكلم في فعلًا كان في فرصة استثمارية طارحها
ويبغاني أدخل معه في الشّركة
وكنت منغمس معه في حوار واجتماع مهم
وفجأة، أنا عادةً في الاجتماعات أحط التلفون على الصامت
بس لقيت فجأة اتصالات من المسؤول عن المطبخ عندنا، الشيف
ما رديت عليه، بس لقيت غير العادة اتصال خمسة وستة وسبعة اتصالات
أنا قلت: حريق وللا شيء وللا، الله يستر
فاستأذنت من الصديق العزيز، وقلت له: برد على المكالمة
ورديت، ولقيت أنه يكلمني، أنا سووا لي جرد اليوم في الهذا
ولقيت في فرق ربطتين بقدونس
وأنا، والله العظيم، أني ما هذا وهو كان آخر يوم في الشهر
ولازم علشان يأخذ مكافأته لازم يلقى حل لمشكلة ربطتين البقدونس هذه
أنا قلت له: ربطتين البقدونس هذه أيش تأكد، وين لقيتهم؟
خوي هذا يقول لي: أيش هذا اللي تارك الاجتماع، ويتكلم عن ربطتين بقدونس
المهم قلت له: خلاص الموضوع أبدًا طبق النظام الموجود عندك
وأبدًا أبشر ما في مشكلة
إذا كان الموضوع ربطتين بقدونس، مقدور عليها
وحطيت السماعة، أخوي هذا قال لي: أنت صادق؟
أنت تدقق في ربطتين بقدونس؟ يوم حطيت السماعة
قلت: لا والله الموضوع مو بكذا، قال: لا هونا ما عاد نبيه
فالحين زعلان علي
إذا البقدونس وكذا سويت فيه، استثمار ما يدري أيش بتسوي فيه
ألغى الاستثمار
وبعدها بدأتوا الشغل على المطبخ، أيش اللي صار؟
مطبخ البيت أسّسناه بطريقة بدل ما كان أول مركز تكلفة
ويمكن أبو عبد الرحمن، أنت تعرف الكثير من العوائل
موضوع المطبخ، والشراكة فيه هذا مشكلة
كانت تكلفة، بس مجرد ندفع تكاليف، ولا ندري أيش يصير فيه
ندفع رواتب العاملين والمشتريات وكذا، ونتوزعها وبس
وجدنا في هدر، وعدم عدالة، وجودة منخفضة، وإزعاج بصراحة
فمكتب العائلة أخذ على عاتقه بتوجيه من المساهمين
وفكرة كانت طرحت من مكتب العائلة
تعالوا نبي ننظم المطبخ، ونحوله من مركز تكلفة إلى ربح
وربح معناته استدامة مو معناته نأخذ فلوس، نبي نغطي تكاليفه بس
وطبّقنا عليه فعلًا مبادئ التجارية اللي يطبقها أي فندق في مطبخه المركزي
رفعنا مستوى الخدمة، عملنا قائمة طعام، وأسعار
وأخذنا في الاعتبار أن الأعسار هذه تكون أقل من السوق
بحيث أنها تغطي بس التكلفة، ما يصير فيها ربح
نظمنا العمل، حطينا سياسات وإجراءات للطلب
وللمشتريات وللموارد البشرية
حطينا سياسة مكافآت، وهذه، الله يهديه، الشيف اللي فشلني فيها
راعي ربطة البقدونس، وجدنا أن الطاقة الإنتاجية، والطلبات زادوا
رضى العائلة بشكل كامل زادت بشكل كبير
صار في ضغط أن يا جماعة نبي نطلب
صديقي الفلاني ذاق الأكلة هذه عندنا، ويبغى يفتحها برة
وخصوصًا أن تصادف هذا في فترة الوالدة، الله يغفر لها ويرحمها
وشاركت في وضع الوصفة لكل طبق من الأطباق
فصار في وصفة خاصة للبيت، فما تتخيل كيف صارت تجينا الضغوط
أن افتحوا وارسلوا لنا، وبندفع فلوس تكفون ما يخالف
فاضطرينا فعلًا نفتح لبعض الأصدقاء والأقارب
اضطريت، أنتوا ما تبون، والحين ربحان صح؟
والحين أبشرك ربحان، وتحول لكيان ربحي
ومن فكرة المطبخ أسسنا شركة «كيترينق» الآن برة
اسمها «يور شيف» وسوينا لها علامة تجارية، وسوينا لها كذا
وأبشرك الآن بدأت تأخذ دورها في تقديم خدمات الإعاشة وتقدم الطعام
لشركات، وبنوك كبيرة، وأُسر في مناسبات زواج أو أعياد واحتفالات
وهذه ترجعنا أبو خالد النقطة الأساسية
أن لو الإدارة التنفيذية خارقة في التشغيل، أو عفوًا أفراد العائلة
غارقين في التنفيذ والتشغيل والعبء اليومي
يمكن ما كان عندهم الوقت للتفكير بالأشياء الأخرى وتنظيمها وترتيبها
واستقطاب المختصين في كل جانب
صحيح
وهذه من بركات الحوكمة والتنظيم
وتركيز أفراد العائلة على أدوار غير الأدوار التشغيلية
أنا بختم بسؤال وهو حلو أنه يكون في الختام
لأنه يلخص يمكن القصة كلها
لما جيت أتحدث معك، الله يسلمك، عن فرصة استثمارية
كنت تقول لي: أنه لازم نستأذن من الشّركة العائليّة
مع أن هذا كان استثمار خاص لك أنت
ولكنك ذكرت، وبعدين أنا اطلعت عليها في الميثاق وشفتها
الشّركة الأم لها الأولوية في أي استثمار يجي لأفراد العائلة
تروح للشركة الأم أولًا، إذا الشّركة الأم ما تبيه أو مستغنية عنه
وقتها يحق لك تدخل، ولازم تفصح للشركة الأم عن استثمارك
حتى ما يكون في تعارض مصالح
وبعدين أنت ربطتها بموضوع الميثاق
وأهمية تحديد رؤية للشركة العائليّة
بحيث أن أي استثمار ضمن رؤيتها، ممنوع أنت يا الفرد تدخل فيه
لو بنختم اللقاء بموضوع رؤية الشّركة العائليّة
وتعارضها مع استثمارات الأفراد
صحيح، من أهم مبادئ الحوكمة أبو عبد الرحمن
هو معالجة قضية تضارب المصالح
واليوم تشوف نظام الشّركات السّعودي، وفي أي دولة
ونظام هيئة السوق المالية في تركيز كبير على أن الشفافية ونزاهة
ووضوح تعامل الأطراف ذوي العلاقة
هذا الموضوع إذا ما ضُبط راح يدخلك في إشكاليات تضارب المصالح
اللي تكلمت عنها
ففعلًا احنا عندنا أي عضو يرشّح ليكون عضو مجلس إدارة
الميثاق فصل بين الأعضاء اللي في مجلس الإدارة، واللي خارجه
العضو اللي خارج مجلس الإدارة له الحق يمارس أعمال واستثمارات
وتأسيس شركات بشكل أكبر، ونطاق أوسع
المحظور الوحيد عليه هو أنه ينافس
ما تدخل في قطاع ينافس الشركة العائليّة
أنت كمساهم تطلع في كل سنة على تقرير الإدارة والشّركة
وتعرف المجالات، فيجب عليك أنك ما تنافسها
وإذا نافستها فالشركة، أو جمعية المساهمين لها الحق أنها تصوت
بأنها تشتري منك هذا العمل بأسلوب، وإجراء معين
أعضاء مجلس الإدارة اللي في المجلس يُحضر عليهم
بالإضافة لهذا الموضوع، أنهم يؤسّسون أي شركة في أي قطاع
لأن قد يكون قطاع من ضمن اهتمامات الشّركة
ولكن لسّه ما بعد دخلت فيه
لهم بس الحق في استثمار أموالهم في الأدوات النقدية
وفي الأسهم المتداولة، والصناديق
غير الثلاثة هذه أي عضو من أعضاء مجلس الإدارة
يجب أن يُفصح عن أي استثمار يبي يسويه لمجلس الإدارة
ومن ثم لجمعية المساهمين
وبالإضافة لهذا الموضوع بعدما يأخذ الإفصاح
للشركة العائليّة الحق في أي وقت أنها تجي
وتقول: تعال والله أنا هذا القطاع عاجبني
وأنت بدأت شركتك فيه، أبغى
أستحوذ عليها وأضمها للشركة العائليّة
وأبي أشتريها منك شراء بتقييم وبأسلوب تجاري بحت
فهذا الموضوع ساهم في زيادة الثقة، وهنا اللي أتكلم
كيف البنات الأخوات زادوا حصصهم واشتروا
يوم شافوا كيف الشفافية والوضوح والثقة، والسيطرة اللي على الأطراف
تعاملات الأطراف ذوي العلاقة
وزاد في بناء بيئة الشّركة، يا أبو عبدالرحمن
اليوم واستقطاب الكفاءات اللي تكلمنا عنها
لولا وجود الأشياء هذه لما جاوا ولا..
لأن وحدة من الممارسات المعروفة في الشّركات العائليّة
أن يجي الأخ اللي له سلطة، وللا له صوت
ويضبط نفسه يسوي له شركات أو يتعاقد مع الشركة العائليّة
بالضبط
أي مدير تنفيذي نزيه ما راح يقبل هذه الممارسات
صحيح
والإخوان اللي ما استفادوا من هذا الإجراء
أكيد أنهم بيشعرون بظلم، وخيانة من هذا الأخ اللي استغل
صحيح
فأنتوا كل جمعية عمومية سنويًا تستعرضون كل الفرص
اللي ينوي الشخص يدخل فيها كعضو مجلس إدارة
نعم
وتوافق عليها الجمعية أنك تدخل، وللا لا
بالنسبة لأعضاء مجلس الإدارة تعرض عليهم أولًا
هي تعرض على الشركة أولًا
وتبدي الشّركة رغبتها، وللا لا في البداية بالأساس
بعدين إذا قالت الشركة: أنا ما أبغى، تُعرض على مجلس الإدارة
لأن قد يكون في توجه استراتيجي
مجلس الإدارة يوافق عليها بعدين ترفع للجمعية العمومية، لأخذ
أنا استمتعت بالحوار جدًّا، أبو خالد
ودّي أني أختمه، طال عمرك، بوصفة مختصرة
لو الواحد اليوم سمع الحلقة هذه
واقتنع بأنه يحتاج ينطلق من نقطة معينة
لو تلخص لنا توصيتك بعد هذه التجربة
لهذا المستمع اللي يبغى يؤسس مبادئ الحوكمة
وترتيبات الشّركات العائليّة في شركتهم، أيش بتنصحه؟
إذا تسمح لي بس أرجع وأتكلم شوي عن بيئة الشّركات العائليّة السّعودية
وتاريخها شوي في الخلافات فيما يتعلق في الخلافات
أنا أذكر بشكل واضح، وزي ما أشوفك قدامي
كيف الملك سلمان، الله يحفظه ويطول عمره
من يوم ما كان أمير منطقة الرياض إلى صار ولي عهد
كيف كان يتدخل شخصيًا في حل كثير من الإشكالات بالشّركات العائليّة
صحيح
وسمو الأمير محمد ولي العهد، الله يطول عمره
بالمبادرات اللي خلقها اليوم، وإعادة الهيكلة، والتنظيمات والتشريعات
حط في اعتباره الكلام هذا بشكل واضح
سمو ولي العهد أنا أعرف أنه في تواصل مع وزارة التجارة
ومع معالي الدكتور «ماجد القصبي» اللي دعم الشّركات العائليّة
ومحاولة الحد من الهدر الناتج من التفكك والخلافات
فاللي أنا أقوله احنا اليوم في بيئة غير مسبوقة في السّعودية
لخلق كيانات تجارية كبيرة، وشركات عائلية راح يكون لها دور
ما هو بس على مستوى الاقتصاد السّعودي
على مستوى الاقتصاد العالمي
وخصوصًا مع الفرص اللي راح تخلقها رؤية 2030
ويمكن في تجارب كثير في الدول في كوريا وأمريكا وأوربا
شركات عائلية صار لها صيت كبير
اليوم هونداي في كوريا، وسامسونج اللي خلقته واللي سوّته
هو نتيجة تنظيم العمل العائلي
والإيمان أولًا بأن فعلًا الوحدة والاتحاد مع بعض والتنظيم والشفافية
هي الطريق لخلق نجاح بهذا المستوى
فأنا أولًا أعتقد الشّركات العائليّة السّعودية بحاجة ماسّة
لأنها تبدأ من اليوم في تنظيم عملها
وصدقني صعوبة الموضوع بأنك لازم تبدأ، والعلاقات جدًّا وثيقة
لأنك تتكلم في أشياء حسّاسة، وتدخل في تنازلات مؤلمة
يا أبو عبد الرحمن لازم تحدث
أنك أنت كمساهم اليوم تتنازل عن جزء من حقك
وهو حقك الشرعي والقانوني والنظامي
في سبيل أنك تساهم في خلق هذا الكيان
هذا قرار لا يمكن أن يتخذه أحد، وهو عنده ذرة شرك في شريكه
أو في أخوه أو أخته، فاللي أقوله أنا: ضرورة وسرعة تنظيم العمل
والبداية من الميثاق العائلي، واليوم وجد كيانات
سواءً كيانات حكومية، وزارة التجارة داعمة بشكل كبير لهذا الموضوع
الله يحفظه الأمير «محمد» داعم في الديوان الملكي
في أكثر من جهة الآن شغالة على الموضوع
المركز «الوطني للمنشآت العائليّة» تم تأسيسه بأمر ملكي
وله دور في هذا الموضوع
الغرف التجارية اليوم عندها تفويض
وعندها أدوات تساعد كثير في هذا الموضوع، المطلوب المبادرة
بإذن الله تعالى، ممتن لك أبو خالد، ولأسرة «السبيعي» الكرام
على إتاحة هذه التجربة الخاصة لعموم المستمعين والمشاهدين
حتى يستفيدون منها، وإن شاء الله، أجرها لكم بإذن الله
الله يحفظك أبو عبدالرحمن، وشاكر لك
تسلم، شكرًا لك يا أبو خالد
وأتمنى، إن شاء الله، ما أكون أزعجنا العائلة إخواني وخواتي
أتمنى أنهم ما يكونوا زعلوا بس
أن زعلوا قُل لهم: احتسبوا الأجر، إن شاء الله
انتظر اتصال أبي أخليك تجي
الله يطول بعمرك، شكرًا يا أبو خالد
الله يحفظك، شكرًا يا أخوي
شكرًا لكم
شكرًا لفهدة القصير في إنتاج هذه الحلقة
ياسر الغانم في إدارة التصوير
غالب جانودي في الإضاءة
ياسر كدشة مساعد إضاءة
وفي التصوير عبد الرحمن عبود
وفي تسجيل وهندسة الصوت عبد العزيز المزي
وفي التحرير أنس الخليل
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج غيداء التميمي، وأصيل بافرط
هذا بودكاست سُقراط
أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع